uh we're not live yet are we I guess
they wait for us so I'm going to go
ahead and initiate uh division three
Finance this is a work session uh
today's topics are the New Hampshire
veterans home and also uh the facility
Administration New Hampshire hospital
Glencliff home Hampstead Hospital so so
a bunch of of institutional Health Care
I'm sorry I'm a little late
we relearned that there are no free
lunches I went down to get something
from the Cancer Society and ended up
getting an earful of why we need to fund
the tobacco secession program so I was
not allowed to walk away with my bag of
chips until I heard all of that so
okay
you ready Mr Ripple
yes the Veterans Home is up first and I
think you've all been given the handout
and the handout is just the letter right
we're not looking at a big PowerPoint
there's a letter and an attached
presentation oh I haven't
okay he ready representative stream are
we live do we know that we're rolling
now
hmm
we're live we're live okay
um so so welcome
and I forget the the great title oh
commandant you're the new commandant we
Peggy lebreck has been there for what
five six years prior to you and she I
think was a commandant for probably
seven years but yes Peggy retired last
March um but I came in last January so
the good news is you've been all through
the budget process this is this is
basically your your budget proposal and
not something you inherited yes oh great
one should both introduce yourself for
the record my name is Kim McKay I'm the
commandant New Hampshire Veterans Home
I'm Stephanie Kelly I'm the business
administrative Veterans Home
and I'll encourage you each time to get
as close to the microphone as possible
and it's it's really for two reasons one
we're broadcasting and taping taping
um and plus I'm deaf so if you use the
microphones it helps so so go ahead and
tell us what you want to tell us so
speaking to you is this our budget it is
our budget I will say that our CFO was
deployed so I was speaking to him from
deployment this morning just to get some
more talking points for this budget so
um you're getting me instead of him so
um this is the operating budget for
24.25 and in this slide deck I put in
there some slides about the history I'm
not sure if everybody's been to the New
Hampshire veterans home or is aware of
the New Hampshire veterans home but it
was established in 1890 served Civil War
veterans and now obviously we serve all
veterans that qualify we are 20 250 bed
facility long-term care no skilled care
and we are supported by the VA and the
residents themselves along with the
general funds so the way it breaks down
is 47 of General funds uh U.S Department
of Veterans Affairs is 29 in individuals
resident room and board is 24 percent
right now we have a budget for 225
residents
um we have not budget up to the 250 Mark
so we've stay at 225
this is the short answer for that for
the difference is that is a Manpower
challenge or we just didn't give you
enough money and yeah we've given you
more money you still wouldn't have the
people I wouldn't have 250. no I think
that it's still Manpower and we're going
to talk about censuses that we go in
here because we are really experiencing
that um that issue uh the mission of the
New Hampshire Veterans Home is to
provide the best quality of life for New
Hampshire veterans with dignity honor
and respect and I will tell you uh that
is uh seen throughout all of our staff
they truly loved what they're doing for
work there our current census is when we
talk about census is 129 residents today
118 men with 11 women the average age is
83 and the average stay for us is about
three years some much longer but average
stay is about three years
can I ask you a question about that I I
haven't flipped through your uh
presentation but
um when I've taken tours there uh you
had basically two Wards of roughly the
same size uh one was meant to explicitly
be like a dementia Alzheimer's Ward the
other was not intended for that but
nevertheless it's my memory says you had
75 percent of those patients were
nevertheless having experiencing they
were experiencing dementia is that still
roughly true yes sir so uh maybe not to
the point where living on a uh we call
him a Ladue Life Enhancement dementia
unit those units are reserved for people
who may be wandering risks and for their
safety they're in that unit
um but yes about 75 percent have some
type of a memory disorder whether it's
due to Parkinson's or dementia but yes
that's correct all right thank you
um uh the always whenever we're asked so
to speak we talk about who what branches
and it's a very competitive thing if you
come to the veterans home which I would
openly welcome anybody who would like to
have a tour they're going to ask you
right away are you a veteran the
resident's going to ask you are you a
veteran and then what branch so I break
it down uh Air Force we have 28
residents Air Guard one resident Army 55
which is our biggest group of people
Coast Guard one Marines four and navy is
40 so they're right behind I'm a little
surprised and I'm surprised with this
breakout mostly because
New Hampshire has more of a history of
having an Air Force present with peas
[Music]
and so uh
they're kind of low on this isn't it
they are about 28 Air Force yeah is that
because they just go somewhere else I
don't know I'm not sure all right I'm
not sure conflict era served we have 11
World War II veterans right now honestly
every time I do this uh presentation it
I sadly see the number decrease Korean
conflict 42 residents Vietnam era is our
biggest group at 65 residents Gulf War
one and uh during peacetime 10 and I
think that's what we're going to see is
that we're going to see a lot of post
veterans coming in as our World War II
veterans um
Fade Out
challenges and achievements there's two
things that are really on the table and
that they're they're so interrelated and
one is Recruitment and Retention of
Staff both clinically and non-clinically
we've seen over the history for State
positions that people would take any
kind of position in the support services
just to get in the door and for the
first time we're really feeling those
vacancies like in our dietary food
service area but along with our clinical
which everybody is probably talked about
to you is that we have the challenge of
trying to find nurses and L A's
um so one of the things that we have
done to really try to tackle this issue
is launch into an internal LNA program
so we have uh we have gone to the board
of nursing we have been approved and
we've been teaching an L A course so we
do earn as you learn and we hire people
part-time as an l a trainee and then
they work with us while they're taking
the class in our facility working with
our veterans and then when they graduate
they commit to being with us for a year
so with that program in the last fiscal
year we've had been able to add 16 new
lnas to our um say the number again 16.
so and you think the 16 are going to
stick for at least a year at least a
year yes and but we don't have a lot of
experience yet on longer term retention
we don't no we just started this we've
had three classes we have another one
starting at the end of April beginning
of May how long is the class it takes
about eight to nine weeks and to go
through the class but we hired them
before that so they don't have to wait
until that time we'll be hiring them as
we go and they work part-time as a like
an l a trainee get to know our residents
they can do some of the things on site
and then once they're licensed they go
into a full-time position so so relative
to an LNA is an Mna more trained or or
not more trained more trained yes so the
second thing we did is we also went to
the Board of Nursing and submitted a
curriculum to teach the m a program
which is a medication nursing assistant
so you have to be an LNA to qualify for
two years and then pass a pre-test and
we we have to feel confident that you
can do those skills and so we have uh
got that program approved in the
meantime we would have been paying for
it out of our education fund to have
people take the class and that are
working for us because I really feel
like how we're going to retain people is
that we invest in them and we say it's
important that you're here and we're
we're glad you're here and if you want
to keep going let let's keep going we
would love to see them progress in their
education so the military has two
components on that one is they provide
skills and education development but
then they also have the notion of an
obligated service and or in a payback if
you fail to meet your service are these
programs also connected to an obligation
as much as we can so as the state we
have asked them to they sign a learning
contract that says if they leave within
a year then their program is prorated so
if they stay for six months they have to
pay back the half of the cost of the
program we haven't had anybody leave yet
so we haven't had to challenge that I
don't know how much leeway we'll have on
that or how much enforcement we can have
but we ask them to commit to that and
we've seen them commit so far okay
we also have reclass a vacant position
that we had into a recruiter and just
specializing in recruitment so going to
job fairs doing reaches reach outs to
um colleges before high schools we're
speaking at high schools we're just
trying every Avenue we can to reach
those that might be interested in
working with the Americans Heroes so
we're trying really hard I'm back at the
l a thing because was there such
Workforce issues all over the place I
just want to see what we can maybe learn
from your experience
of these 16
what kind of demographic are we talking
about are we talking predominantly
female predominantly under the age of 25
or we getting a lot of folks coming out
of the
Workforce back into nursing well there's
been a little combination we actually
have had a couple of people from our
housekeeping Department who have been
with us for years
I would not want to venture a guess of
their age because they may not like that
probably over 25 over 25 that's a great
way to do that you wouldn't card them I
would not card them no no
um but we are seeing a younger group of
people come in
um I would say under 25 but the but
that's the majority but um we have staff
that have been with us that worked in
housekeeping and thought wow I'd really
like to be an LNA
um thought well let me try it and we've
had two staff members graduate and have
transferred from that department to
become an LNA so and then from a radius
perspective are they nearby and this was
really convenient yes yes sir do you
have any stats on what proximity we're I
don't but I can get those and get them
back to the committee it's not urgent
but I I just be curious because everyone
is trying to figure out how to solve
this part of the problem and I I just
would like to know what your success
criteria is representative thank you
very much an extension off of the
Chairman's inquiries into the program
can you give us an idea what the
starting pay is for someone who's
entering this program
I would think 16 I think it was like 14
16 an hour
okay thank you so it's pretty low and
that's part of what we deal with on an
ongoing basis is that we're just not
competitive with the community it's
helped having the enhancements
um but we know that some of that
enhancement money is going away on June
30. and so we're hoping the raise will
help a little bit but it's really tough
to get people who want to dedicate uh
work any shift be mandated to stay
because if there's no one to come in for
that shift and they're going to have to
stay to provide the care and provide
very personal care to somebody for the
fees that we're paying
so because of the security of these
patients you really need a lot of
Hands-On support I'm guessing that this
isn't something that you're going to
really extend through telemedicine for
example this all has to be in the
building Hands-On yes sir yes sir
and have the personality to do it to to
be able to do that type of work
um so we've tried to improve onboarding
and retention with more support in
mentorship we're improving our
orientation so that people don't feel
like they just come into work for the
first day we do one day orientation and
send you out there we want to try to
provide more orientation we are
improving the communication when I came
the not all staff had email only about
50 percent did so we've upped the email
to include everyone we have received
some arpa funds to help with some
communication boards that are going to
go up in in our common areas so that one
if we're in an outbreak status for covid
or we have any kind of changes in the
way we do our business like wearing
goggles instead of not wearing goggles
those will be communicated to the staff
quickly and then we also do hero Awards
where we just really recognize our staff
for outstanding uh work that they do
that challenge goes in with low staff
that means that we can't meet the needs
for higher census and let me ask you
some questions about your census yes
here you say it's 131
based on about 50 Staffing
um
I assume that there's kind of a step
increment here that as you get more
people you can incrementally fill more
beds right yes so you know what how far
are you away from that next jump in
occupancy pretty far uh because right
now on our second shift nursing staff we
have about two full-time staff the rest
of the second shift is being staffed
with staff who are doing mandatory
overtime voluntary overtime and so
that's that second shift that we're
really feeling the lack of staff that
affects us and so we we did we were
granted um through the fiscal the
finance committee and GNC at temporary
staffing contract that we came to for
last summer and that contract
um the company has been able to provide
zero people zero we have not had one
staff we've asked multiple times so at
this point we are rewriting a new
Staffing contract that will just be for
just nursing because these previous
Staffing contract was for nursing and
support staff and I think that might
have been the difficulty because nursing
companies staffing companies they
specialize in medical and so when you
add food service workers in there was
less of a choice for companies so we're
going to go back out and try
um so at 130 and I'm a little bit of
hurry because I know sorry I'm just
trying to get us done at 1 30 and I I'm
the one that asks most of the questions
so it's my fault but at 131 you got to
have a wait list do you have a slide in
here that talks about your weight loss
our waitlist currently is 20 people have
been approved to come in but they don't
have a bed because we can't offer them a
bed
an additional five who have been
approved and asked to don't want to come
in right now they want to be on the list
for a lot longer they feel like this was
just a step to make sure they could come
in and then we have about 65 other
people who have have an application and
process so it's in place in some form so
it might just be the first day they put
it in or they actually have are waiting
for their medical information or their
Finance so I may be imagining this but I
I think I was at like an S fact meeting
or something listen to the prior coming
down and I think she recommended
that even people
who don't need nursing home care now go
ahead and begin the application process
so that the paperwork sort of pre-done
and and so I'm a veteran and I'm just
wondering when I should fill out my
paperwork well I I have a different view
I feel that you should probably wait
until you need us or you're close to
needing us and I I don't think you look
like you're close to needing us yeah
depending on how this budget goes we
don't know okay all right so I don't
need to be worrying about you don't need
to worry about that so the the neat
people that you're are seeing that
number our people excluding the five P
five people that could come in today if
we could provide the beds and we just
can't provide the bed safely we can't
meet the needs and make our regulatory
needs uh for the VA or our commitment to
those to those veterans that are there
so 131 is the cap where we said we can
we can do this to 131 and that's looking
at each unit and our staffing for each
unit and today we're at 129 with pending
admissions
okay I'm just going through here to see
if there are slides that sort of give us
all the number I wanted to really
emphasize is that our the 131 is
matching up with our 51 vacancy rate
with nurses and 45 with lnas and I think
it's lower with lnas because we have the
program that we can create in lnas right
so I don't know if you remember the
history on this were you were you
employed at the veterans swim two three
years ago I was not I was at glencliffe
okay so so so you might have heard that
what the previous division three did was
we took the governor's recommendation
and basically approved it so so I'm uh
to the to what extent do you have some
unusual budget requests that might jump
out at us as something we need to be
aware of because I think in the past
we've been generally supportive of your
mission and your resourcing yes so I
think um if I were if I were in your
shoes I'd be looking at Big differences
and what I would probably bring your
attention to uh mostly is around
um our consultant fees we had a doctor
who was with us for many many years
um and business on a particular page
looking at the actual budget the budget
so
um
yes and this is under 53.59 you'll see
our contracted Services have gone up and
that's due to us having a contract out
for our medical providers and and we
that contract will expire during this
time and so we are forecasting what we
think might happen without contract the
other cost which I think a lot of people
are experiencing is the increase in
prescription drugs and again we're
forecasting but we have
um we have veterans who come in we had
just had an admission recently where a
veteran is taking a Parkinson medication
then it can't be changed it's thirty six
thousand dollars each month so you'll
see a pretty big jump in the
prescription cost and that's again
forecasted we don't know who our new
admissions will be and what kind of
medications but that's what we're
forecasting out to see that we might
need uh the the extra funds for
other than that I think it's we stayed
within the governor's parameters
representative do you have a yeah I'm
just looking at the numbers
um online zero six zero under
benefits I hope I'm looking at the right
line
um it went from 6.4 million in 2022 up
to 10.4
and then it stays at like that 10
million number
um is that online page 1097
1097.
under Professional Care line zero six
zero I'm just curious if you knew what
caused that big jump there
in that line those would be our um is
that our overtime line is that what
you're saying
benefits we we don't have so when we
have more overtime it has more benefits
but we don't have a lot of control over
those lines honestly those are set
um by the Personnel what the benefit
costs are to us so
[Music]
um
foreign
and now we're asking for nine million
eight and ten million three I was just
curious what fault I'm sorry yes yes
fell under that line item that had the
increase of four million dollars in the
last biennium do you have that answer
go ahead
that would just be because every all the
all the um overtime pay and
um that'll increase as we go and every
year I've had to do adjustments into it
so we increased it
oh I'm sorry and I'm looking up at the
top at overtime line where it was 1.1
and then it dropped down so I see there
was a bit of a shift there so yeah okay
instead of having to come back and ask
for that to be in the correct line it's
in the correct line now thank you
yeah
so so one of the things that I think
you've done that addressed uh some
family uh concerns that I had heard over
the last few years was
um that you you really only had the one
Wi-Fi network that supported the staff
primarily and that there was some
sharing from some of the patients of
that but that was extremely limited I
understand that you've now got two
separate Wi-Fi systems so that patients
can now or residents whatever the right
term is are now able to enjoy as much
bandwidth as they need to to movies
communicate with their family do email
all of that stuff yes sir is that is
that project completed no so that's part
of it
um uh Peggy lebrick was able to get that
in place but we were also able to ask
for Abra funds because of our building
its Wi-Fi is not completely steady
throughout the whole building so you
have to be in certain areas to be able
to access it so we have got a 1.1
million dollars to invest in our Wi-Fi
system as well as our communication
boards and Conference so we have an IT
project underway and that the improve
the goal is to improve the communication
for the residents so they can
communicate with their families no
matter where they are we don't have to
go to a certain area or know which rooms
are the best rooms so if you have
somebody who wants to use their computer
a lot that's the best room for them to
have as a resident room so and so could
you summarize some of the covet
restrictions that might still be in
place are you still requiring masks for
everyone are you still requiring the
injection for every employee and for
every patient what talk just generally
about code so our covid right now we are
currently actually in a coveted outbreak
we have been since December because
every time somebody gets coveted
prolongs it you have to have two full
weeks of clean testing with no positives
Friday will be our last clean test
hopefully and we'll be off but we
haven't had any veterans have coveted
since uh January 31st so it's all been
staffed just kind of the stuff
with that said though when you're in
outbreak we actually do we still wear
goggles
um and if we are in an outbreak with a
resident area the residents are staying
in their unit we have a quarantine unit
we wear PPE gowns gloves and 95 masks
but traditionally every day if we're not
an outbreak we are wearing the uh
surgical mask still with them
and so what's that doing to your
visitation policy
um I I don't think it's changed anything
I think that the the family members of
the residents come in no matter what and
they'll wear whatever they need to to
see them we are opening up a little bit
more having visitors come in we have a
lot of veterans support organizations
that come in and do cookouts and those
kinds of outings and so we just have
under 10 and it's an example recently we
had the l a graduation they were able to
bring two people or three people this
one we did three people each family so
we're starting to slowly put
the
visits open a little bit more for the
residents and the families
all right any other questions
representative nordgren anything
anything all right
they they
yes she always does a good job thank you
thank you again I would love to extend
um an invitation to the facility if
anybody would like to come and tour and
see what we do
um pick out a room you know in the
future I want the one with the view you
want the one with it and internet those
are my two criteria and something with a
bathroom would be good oh private
bathroom is a little harder to come by
but we'll see what we can do yeah and
and where did your CFO deploy
um he is actually in Pembroke because
he's on the I don't know the term but
the back side he's on the he's a major
and he's supporting the team that's on a
front line so he is actually in Pembroke
which was very convenient for me today
so his rough duty is Pembroke I know
right don't say that to him all right
we'll just say deployed all right
um all right well thank you so much
thank you
I think that answers everything okay
so
how about
are there any preferences out in the
audience there and I see the
commissioner is entered do you want to
say anything to us or are you just like
watching or
thank you oh are you which one's your
topic ma'am
why don't you go come up and we'll let
you go first
good afternoon nice to see you all again
it may be surprising that I'm going to
speak to you about facilities but I will
explain why
I know my staff have done a fantastic
job of uh coming and presenting to you
all of our our programs facilities is a
little bit uh different
um as many of you know I was Deputy
Commissioner prior to this role that I'm
in now and Facilities was in my
portfolio and has been for quite some
time we have had a significant amount of
turnover in facilities between admin
services and HHS so when we think about
institutional knowledge walking out the
door it did walk out the door I mean
people were retiring it's not that it
was a horrible place to be it was really
about after covid many people took early
retirement or retired so we're in a
position
um
where some of that has happened so I
have hired a facilities director who I
have here with me today but this is um
this isn't she Tammy's in her first year
Tammy Nelson is our facilities director
so what I wanted to share with you is
the last budget cycle there was a change
to how facilities would be
taken care of for Health and Human
Services so many people may or may not
know but in 2005 we had an agreement
with Department of admin services and
health and human services for how they
would take care of our property so we
have quite a bit of space we have the
State Office Park South Campus we have
the Hazen Drive campus we have our 24 7
institutions we have 11 district offices
we have 26 leases
which the 11 offices are part of that
but we also have itinerant offices so as
you can imagine that's a lot of people a
lot of square footage a lot of
facilities work Das was uh always uh we
had an mou where we had 38 distinct
items that they would be or activities
that they would be helping us with last
budget cycle that was a change Das was
to centralize their services so that
moving to a cost allocation model that
they would be providing services to any
Agency on Sops campus which makes sense
from their perspective but for us it's a
little bit of a hit because we now don't
have some of those extra sets of hands
if you will to to deal with the enormity
of some of our needs so
our presentation today is a lot focused
on a lot of it's focused on that what's
going to be different for the department
and the next biennium is really building
up a little bit of our own
infrastructure that we have the way
we've always broken it out is that
patient buildings
were always the responsibility of HHS so
when you think about New Hampshire
hospital it's on the grounds so Das
takes care of the snow plowing they take
care of the flowers and the grass and
all of those things but they take care
of nothing inside so when we had a water
break there when we had that cold snap a
couple of weeks ago and it flooded we
HHS take care of that not Das whereas
when the flooding happened in one of our
district offices that was a lease space
we have a landlord and working with us
on Claremont we had two district offices
have water leaks or so we had four
events in three days it was quite an
event for us so point being is that
sometimes we have the help sometimes we
don't so we need to build that into our
system so our facilities
you know I think we have here you know
26 leases 325 000 square footage
approximately 228
about about thereabouts is for the
district offices so you get a sense for
that
um so
if you flip to slide three I did want to
invite Tammy to be able to share a
little bit and have a little bit of a
presentation in terms of what she's
tasked with with doing so we're sharing
this presentation a little bit
good afternoon my name is Tammy Nelson
director of facilities thank you for
having me
as Lori mentioned
um
we oversee and manage 26 lease
facilities and how we do that really is
broken down into two areas of designated
Focus
one is facilities maintenance which
consists of the overall management of
lease space in order to service the
clients in Regional locations
is that better
do you want me to back up okay
so with facilities maintenance we are
responsible essentially to procure
design in a reconfigure office space to
meet the operational needs of the
department
to ensure safety and accessibility of
HHS facilities and to ensure the
facilities are maintained properly
we have at this time four full-time
facility coordinators who manage all
logistics for the district and itinerant
offices
secondly we have office services which
provides support functions to all the
HHS locations Statewide those Services
include mail purchasing inventory And
archiving Logistics transportation and
Fleet Management Services
in addition to the field locations as
the commissioner mentioned the bureau
provides oversight in management of the
the four campus locations
Governor Governor's Office Park South
sununu Youth Services Center glencliffe
home and Hampstead Hospital
we work collaboratively with general
maintenance equipment failures and
purchases emergency repairs resource
allocation and on special or unplanned
projects
we also identify capital projects and
operational efficiencies
okay so I just want to pick at I think
you're we're on slide four one of the
second bullets there sununu Youth
Services Center
150 acres 13 buildings
of those 13 buildings
how many of them are really actively
used by the sununu youth center right I
know there's one huge complex
where
hallways connect everything I assume
that counts as one building but I don't
know but then also there are kind of
like historic buildings or buildings
that need to be torn down are how do
they figure in that count
well they we own the property so we're
responsible to maintain it right so Das
helps us maintain it
um the the youth are in the new the
newer building it's not new anymore we
have a building called the
administration building which might be
the building that you're thinking about
and I don't know if that counts as
wanters too but we do use that the staff
use that so we may not have youth in
there but we have staff in there the
State Police use one of the buildings
for its state police right for the horse
uh equestrian there's some training
there but then we have buildings you'll
see one of our capital projects was to
demolish Wilkins building so even though
it may not be in useful responsible for
making sure that it's a safe environment
and if it needs to come down it comes
down we have the where the boiler is
that supports the property the roof is
done and falling in so we have to make
plans for that because that boiler
supports the property so they're
intertwined but youth aren't in any of
the other buildings right which is kind
of the point I wanted to Elevate is that
when we talk about the cost of the
sununu youth center
the cost of this entire real property
gets to be allocated to the sununu youth
center which in my view overstates the
cost of current operations
is a fair I mean like for example the
equestrian center for the State Police
is do they reimburse you a fair price
for that or or is that something the
sununu youth center is uh subsidizing or
funding yeah I think it's an in-kind we
let them use it in kinds like we have
we don't exchange money on it uh board
that for that particular piece of it and
I don't know what their utilization is I
know they're using it for storage I mean
it's not heated uh I shouldn't say it's
not heated I don't it's it's
um
it's not like any of the other
facilities where it's it's um
it's a barn
right it's a barn and a rodeo pen and a
bunch of others and then they're like
three old buildings when you pull all
the way in that are brick off to the you
know and so my my maybe this is a Mr
White question if we were to put a cost
estimate on all of that land and and
property or buildings
uh how how big a number are we talking
about that isn't directly related to
taking care of our juvenile mission
when you say cost estimate are are you
talking about like what what on what
costs are not directly related to the
operations associated with the children
that are there is is that what you're
indicating that that's where I'm going
like like when you when you pull all the
way through in the in the in the main
entrance and and there's the the two or
three brick buildings in the on the
short Horizon with this new new center
to your left those buildings are not
being used to support the ju the sununu
youth center mission
and I'd like to know
how much a fair cost estimate would be
of all that extra property that gets
hung around the neck of this Nunu Center
when it's really a cost allocation issue
that you guys are eating for other
departments and other uses does that
make the question more clear or more
complex no that's clear I I think I'd
have to go back and take a closer look
at a you know what what we have in the
syc uh operating account what do we have
here what are the sort of uh
non-denomenal non-denominational in-kind
matches that we have today to come up
with an accurate figure for you okay so
why is this relevant it's not just an
academic issue it's relevant to me
because at some point I have a dream and
in this dream there's a new sununu or
whatever that we're going to call it a
replacement facility for the current
sununu Center and and this new new
Mission will the youth center Mission
will no longer be on that campus
yet the state will still have ongoing
cost obligations for that campus it just
won't go under this Nunu expense lines
so I'm just curious when it's all said
and done what are we going to be left
with after the replacement Center has
been opened and what line of accounting
will be used
in the future to to pay for the required
maintenance the demolition the mowing
the lawn you know all of that stuff
I'm just curious about the longer term
View
your term view is on and there has been
desire expressed by the governor to sell
the property
um I think if we move our services out
of there HHS I mean Das would assume
that that responsibility for maintaining
that campus just as they do for any
other state property as long as the
state owns it
okay so rather than
DHHS riding the check Das will write the
check
it the state isn't saving money and it's
just changing who pays for it and so I'm
I just would like us to be able to
anticipate what that that amount of
money will end up being because although
we have said that we'd like to sell it
we said we wanted to sell Laconia right
and that took a decade or more so so I'm
I'm just curious what the long-term Tale
on this property is going to be I think
representative hole you had a question
it may I I think Jess needs to be a part
of that conversation as well because the
minute we vacate that property they
become responsible for that property so
I imagine that they have their own
Protocols of what they need to do if
that property is no longer going to be
utilized they have a protocol that they
follow where they're shutting down
building and and winterizing it or
taking it out of use so they would be
better able to project what those costs
would be
okay I'll maybe next budget cycle if I'm
here we'll ask Das what that estimate is
but it feels to me like it's got to be a
couple million dollars a year that's
generally what I'm feeling from this I
don't know if that's reasonable
do you have any reason to think that's
not reasonable the building
it's really yeah it's
you know
all right well now it's Houston
speculating I guess representable thank
you along the same line right some of
those buildings for instance the state
police using the oldest brick or the old
brick building just south of of the
training and writing and exercise arena
for the equestrian
portion of their whatever the state
police
how many of those buildings are heated
not heated and right how many are cold
storage how many could be mothballed not
right because some buildings you don't
want to just winterize if you winterize
the building it quickly falls into
disrepair and is no longer usable so if
you guys have any insight or maybe
someone who is more Hands-On within the
oversight of that those buildings yeah I
mean we can get you that information for
sure
some of them are no longer or they are
mothballed some of them
and even worse
are we good to proceed
I'm still curious about that I I guess
I'm just jumping around exposing my ADD
again but
um I in the missions here I don't really
see who's accountable or where the
function of Space Management is so that
in my in my terminology this was
actually a job additional duty I had
where you know all of the office space
and and clinical space of a of a couple
hospitals I was responsible for
allocating the space to various units
and so I imagine with all of this all
these facilities somebody's doing a
similar function of knowing what's
available who's where and and and it
gets to the point of saying okay this is
this is our picture we have a
significant vacancy problem and so some
of that space is underused now because
we have vacancies we're trying to fill
but but then it gets to the real
management question I think of are we
sitting on excess capacity are we do we
know whether or not we have good active
management of the space is it possible
releasing space that we could actually
solve those requirements in-house and
those those kinds of questions I'd like
to know about the management and to the
extent to which those kinds of
management questions have been asked
over the last couple years so we know
that we're doing a fine job in that
regard sure so if you're at a flip to
Slide Five
there's an org chart here and I have a
yellow box around the left side of that
so that was our mou that we had with Das
so in Partnership our facilities
director with uh with position and Das
would do the Space Management so in
terms of if I have new staff coming on
board you know or the directors do we
let facilities know Tammy Tammy has like
the master macro view of where do we
have space I will tell you that I mean I
was out in three district offices last
week I'll be out in Claremont this
Friday and our officers are packed they
were packed before the pandemic during
the pandemic we worked remotely and then
people are coming back a lot of our
business uh it's hard for us to be 100
remote and I don't think we'll we will
ever be but we are like a hybrid right
so we have we have staff that interface
with clients every single day but they
need a home base to come to and they
need a team so that office is really
important so I was just you know
Rochester's in the middle of a
renovation with the city there's they're
they're just squeaking in there we're
squished into Keen we're squished into
uh not Portsmouth but what was Laconia
we're falling out Laconia so there's
just there's not there's there seems to
be sometimes an assumption that maybe we
have more square footage that we need
when I go on the road boots on the
ground that's not the case I have I have
people sharing cubicles and offices so
we used to have 12 district offices we
now have 11. so we we did this exercise
in the past and and it's really hard of
which office do you close right because
you know they're all scattered
throughout the state and the minute you
close an office you make it harder for
clients to get to your services so
having 11 it's been hard to get below
11. now I will tell you in Claremont
we're looking at you know are there ways
that we can make do something different
with that office so when the opportunity
presents itself we're taking it so Lisa
the lease for Laconia is coming up we're
looking at that as well and we're not
looking at it a couple months ahead
we're looking at it months out but
there's just challenges to how we do our
business and landlords that are willing
to work with us so you could in terms of
management that's something that we're
always paying attention to and then the
other part of that sort of the Strategic
realignment in the post-pandemic world
is that uh generally we're probably more
open to some remote support but what I
think I just heard you say is that
that's also being actively considered uh
and and that the potential for that is a
little bit limited because you're such a
client based face-to-face organization
correct and when we have vacancies like
we do we have new staff coming on they
need to be trained they need to be with
other people right I don't know how you
build your culture like you've said you
want to without people being near each
other I don't know how you do that in a
virtual world so so again we're not 100
virtual we have the flexibility to be
able to have the hybrid so like I said
when I go out staff are telling me that
they want to be together they like the
flexibility but it's important to teams
so
so I'm going to jump ahead to six where
you have facility positions requests
yeah and and let's say that these these
uh these positions uh make sense the so
the question
um is is not to ask you to justify these
because what I think I heard you say is
the realignment of the mou with Das has
caused you to to need these positions
internally instead of relying on Das
services so because of that I wonder if
this actually should be some sort of a
funds transfer from a Das budget to you
I don't know if it's a funds transfer as
much as is we don't pay them as much as
what we used to pay them I'll let Nathan
answer that sure so if you turn
if you turn to page
um 1087 of the governor's recommended
budget you look at class 28 transfer to
plant and property
um the the amount that that we have
budgeted in that line this year uh it it
went down significantly
um we did have uh representative Hull
had a question when we were presenting
on uh the Department of Public Health
Services because there was also that
transfer to plant and property for das
there where we saw roughly 500 000
increase but but even if if you take
that that class 28 from from account
5110 within public health and you look
at the amount that we have here in
account 5685 for the class is 28. we I
mean we we are we are seeing a net
decrease there so I I mean one a prudent
person could argue that there would be
sufficient funds to to cover these these
potential costs associated with these
positions
yeah
I don't see any questions at this point
um
I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna let you come
back and back clean up after I just jump
around a little bit may I just add one
piece though representative to the
position part I just want to point out
I'm asking for three I think I had seven
from from Das so we're not asking to
replace the whole thing we're just
basically looked at out of those
functions that we had uh with uh Das
what are the ones that that are no
longer going to be able to be given to
us to the extent that they were like if
you take at least the least position
that isn't just I process the leases
that's day-to-day lease management and
with 26 properties you can imagine
there's a lot that happens with that and
then the two maintenance mechanics so I
just want to point out I'm not asking to
get everything that they had given I'm
asking for these critical positions to
add to Tammy's uh Bureau right and since
you can't read my mind I I would tell
you that I am less concerned about your
request as I am just making sure that by
moving things from Das to your
department that we're not leaving Das as
fully resourced as they had been and
were growing government through the back
door I don't I don't doubt your request
your need for the request I'm I'm more
concerned that the money transfers are
in place and the understandings are in
place so we're not leaving Das with less
Mission and still the same number of
people that that wouldn't make sense to
me sure and I would just also share that
commissioner only house and team in our
teams we met last Friday so they're
they're well aware of we've had this
conversation about impact and moving
forward so I just want to put that out
there in terms of this is this is
something we've been working on together
all right thank you and then I'm I'm
jumping to nine on on bullet five where
you have district offices and client and
Concord and so this this is explicitly
not the New Hampshire hospital for
example this is this is really the stuff
up on Hazen right
um no this is not even Hazen this is
district offices so this is where we
provide the direct client services so I
we we just kept it for the D what we
call the Dos but if we were to add we
would add Hampstead we would add
glencliffe we would add all of the
others we didn't this was just to say
these are the least spaces that we have
some of them okay so of these 11 I I've
heard you voice a concern that things
are fairly tight and many of them
um do you when do you imagine or do you
imagine
wanting to uh affirmatively acquire
additional Space by
expanding the building somehow or or
what what what sort of as you look at I
I know you're you're you're you're think
you're focused on this year but if you
were to be thinking four or five years
out where do you see uh the longer term
facility need
so I'm not thinking about expanding I'm
thinking about doing it differently so
if we if let's just take Claremont for
example
um it's hard we've been trying to move
out of Claremont for seven years seven
years I can't find a landlord that can
match square footage for square footage
so now I'm at a spot where I say well do
I need to do that can I can I do that
business differently I still need to
have a client facing Lobby I still need
to have a back office for staff but do I
have to have it all stuck together like
I normally do and now I have a thing
called remote where I have some
flexibility with seats right so that's
what I'm playing with right now so I
want to sort of pilot what we're going
to do potentially with let's just I'll
pick on Claremont it may not be
Claremont but if we're able to stand up
and and meet our business needs and
doing it differently than it looked like
and it helps us with square footage and
Lease space and then that's what we
should be doing
and um just just following up on
representative walner's request from
yesterday there there is an hb2
provision it's section 241 of hb2 and it
could you state the request and so we
understand your answer sure I apologize
um so yesterday as we were discussing
representative Wallner asked us as we go
through our presentations if there is an
applicable hb2 provision that that we
just draw attention to that so we see
the connections once we start to go
through hb2
um and so section 241 of hb2 that there
was a 533 thousand dollar appropriation
for a district office move
uh thank you for um
doing that and the other thing I was
wanting to do before you leave is maybe
talk about whether you had any
prioritized needs that were not
addressed in the governor's
budgets
for facilities
yeah for this section yes
so I think I've had it in the last
couple of budgets to try to move
district offices which I've told you
it's taken me seven years to find for
Claremont but we did have two we had
money in there for two moves
representative Wallner and we got we got
the one of them
um
and can I just ask where the other one
was
amount or location both
Nathan we have to tell you the amount
but I could tell you the location would
be Laconia because we don't we don't fit
into that space anymore
it would need a re-haul
great thank you
okay so I've completely jumbled go ahead
he's got the amount that we we had made
two separate requests um four or five
hundred and uh thirty three thousand
dollars for each year
um but we were provided one
appropriation for that amount from the
23 Surplus oh she was the same amount
thank you
okay so
um representative Stringham yes so just
in the uh this is the 5685 category
right
um and cross-referencing the other
document with those three three staff
that you requested anywhere in the
budget or would that be something
supplemental that you'd be uh asking us
to fund no so so this this was not
included in our original agency budget
um I was doing my role at the time Tammy
was new in her role at the time and we
were really kind of taking this in it's
been a it's been a more recent analysis
and discussion with the Department of
administrative services to understand
the full implications of of what the the
prior hb2 language did when it struck
down that mou law from 2005. thank you
oh
um and follow different questions are
about six facilities whose leases runs
runs out during this biennium how long
do these releases generally run and uh
you know what do what do you anticipate
in terms of um you know rate change from
this lease to the previous lease
our leases typically Run 10 years but in
terms of rate changes I'm not really
sure I mean we we've been pretty good
with keeping it all within
so my predecessors have worked um very
hard to ensure that we've had full gross
leases
um we have one that's an exception and
going forward
the three I think that are coming up in
this
three that I think you mentioned we have
already started discussions with them
and I'm not expecting anything of great
significance for a rate change I I think
you used the term I'm not familiar with
did you say full growth full growth
g-r-o-s-s yes what is a full growth what
that means is
um essentially we pay a fixed rate
um and we that assumes all operating
costs of the building owner or landlord
so we wouldn't pay utilities separately
janitorial separately you know it's all
inclusive and again we have one
exception to that
and which one is that
that would be Manchester okay
go ahead and represent hole
just out of curiosity on full growth
right so these would not be taxable
properties correct so in the traditional
it's not a net net net type lease or is
it
Nathan I don't understand that
I'm not sure if I follow your question
are we being taxed or is the land owner
have a landlord being on leased property
is the landlord being taxed my
understanding is yes that the state has
an exemption where any state property
does not pay any any local property
taxes but I'm not aware of any exemption
for Alicia thank you
are there any other questions so so I'm
going to just apologize see I jumped all
over through this thing and and you you
know it's because this is your first
budget briefing uh you probably were
really madly prepared to go through
stuff and I've ruined that for you so if
there's anything that you want to come
back and tell us that we didn't talk
about I'm all ears we're all ears
I think we've covered covered everything
um if there are you know any areas you
want us to dig into deeper we're happy
to
okay we'll let you know thank you okay
all right well uh thank you uh very much
we may end up sending you some questions
via email in case they come up as we
look at this diet or more closely
thank you thank you thank you
so is there anyone in the audience I
should have asked this earlier that one
is here they wanted to say something
about the veterans home or about the
facilities
are you stepping up to talk about the
veterans home or facilities no okay
you're stepping up to talk about the New
Hampshire hospital I bet New Hampshire
hospital the path program and Glencliff
home
okay very good uh do and there's a
presentation coming around give us just
one second
so I'm Ellen Lapointe while you're
waiting for your presentations I'm the
CEO at New Hampshire hospital along with
me is Brett Mason he's the Chief
Financial Officer
um between Brett and myself we also
oversee in our roles the path program
and glencliffe home
um there's others in the audience too
that if there's additional questions
that we need more help with then they
can jump in and help us out
and um you have a number of documents
that that Kevin has handed out
um so you will see the the coloring book
I I really enjoy that phrase thank you
representative Mooney
um the PowerPoint presentation or I'm
sorry was that representative Edwards
trademark okay either way
um you also have the the budget briefing
book that that is associated with New
Hampshire hospital
um there's also a position movement
detail this is similar to what we handed
out for the division for children youth
and families just to show how the
positions are moving or whether they're
being transferred and the New Hampshire
hospital
budget begins on page
uh 1056 of the governor's recommended
budget
so all the things you just said I think
I'm tracking on all of them except for
the position reallocation sheet it it
should look like this yellow blue yeah
should be pretty obvious then
foreign
there we go I was going to start with
New Hampshire hospital and then discuss
path and then discuss Glenn Cliff if
that's comfortable with the committee
okay so the coloring book I think is
what Nathan just alluded to the slide
deck for New Hampshire hospital you'll
see
um on slide three that is our mission
and vision statement I don't want to go
through that in great detail but if
there's any questions please feel free
to let me know on slide four it tells
you a little bit of history of New
Hampshire hospital many of you may be
familiar with this but New Hampshire
hospital provides acute inpatient
Psychiatric Services to Citizens
experiencing severe and persistent
mental illness Ms Lapointe I we we
talked to you before the budget numbers
were released right and one of the
reasons we try to do that is so that we
could
um
hone in more sure yeah so so I'm I'm all
I'm also saying that to whoever's
watching why we can fast forward through
some of this is because we did our
homework before the budget got released
that sounds great
so in terms of New Hampshire Hospital's
scope of services I wanted to make a
point to let the committee know New
Hampshire hospital does provide
geriatric inpatient Psychiatry forensic
inpatient Psychiatry we treat adults and
we also can treat medical comorbid
conditions we do not primarily treat
substance use
disorders we don't treat acute Medical
Services we partner with hospitals to be
able to provide that service we also
don't provide diagnostic services and of
course we don't provide outpatient
services I think we have the first
question uh representative Hall
sure I'm jumping ahead great I'm
following after my chair I guess so when
we get to slide nine okay right can we
cover vacancy rates in those positions
as well sure so I do have some vacancy
information that's specific to clinical
positions in front of me
um that would be our biggest
opportunities at this point from a New
Hampshire hospital perspective that
would be speaking to RN's mental health
workers and social services from a RN
standpoint we have a 39 vacancy rate
from a mental health worker standpoint
we have a 30 vacancy rate and from a
social work standpoint we have a 60
vacancy rate
follow-up
so if I look at position page nine right
is it possible that you can provide to
us
or give to us now
sorry can you provide to us now or or
later right of those recommended
positions how many of those are
currently filled and not filled and then
the net direct effect on how many
additional patients could be
treated sure yes I'm happy to provide
you with that information as a follow-up
I will add
um from a census perspective at New
Hampshire hospital our current capacity
is approximately 154 patients I say
approximately because there are times
where we have to fluctuate for private
rooms versus semi-private rooms
depending on patient needs we are at
full capacity at this point at at that
Benchmark the highest capacity that we
have ever had at New Hampshire hospital
is right around 184 187 and at this
point in time our vacancy rates are are
directly impacting our ability to
increase our senses I will also add that
based on what the commissioner was just
speaking about earlier from a water
damage perspective the two units that
are currently vacant at New Hampshire
hospital that makes up that variance of
beds that I just discussed were the
units that were impacted by water damage
and are currently in no shape to be able
to have patients occupy them
so let me reiterate what I just heard
which is there's both a facility issue
as well as a vacancy rate that is
prohibiting additional patients there
correct
What's the timing on the repair of the
facility and what's the plan
um so great question so at this point in
time as of
um probably yesterday between yesterday
and today we've just barely completed
the demolition of the space that we
needed to accomplish due to the water
damage we're at a point where we're
pursuing contracts or estimates for the
repair of the space however it's also at
the same time frame of our hopes to be
able to renovate our enf unit which are
the impacted units you may remember that
when New Hampshire hospital had youth
they were on the enf units and it's been
several years in an attempt to try to
renovate those units to be able to get
them to more of an adult standard and
environment so that renovation project
actually has gone out or will be about
to go out to bid and we're hopeful to be
able to to pursue that unit-based
renovation
at this point in time
so because you're talking about
renovation
um are is this to bring uh the facility
in line with with um relatively recent
jcho standards is jcho one of the
benchmarks you try to meet and and how
are we doing from that perspective thank
you for that question so yes
um we are accredited by The Joint
Commission we had our last survey in
September of 2021
um so our cert they uh survey on a
three-year basis so we do anticipate in
the next year or so seeing them again at
New Hampshire hospital and yes there are
several regulations affiliated with the
environment which are definitely being
taken into consideration during the enf
renovation project
um you know without going into detail
about all of those different
requirements that was part of the
architectural and design process with
the firm that we partnered with to be
able to make sure that we met all those
requirements in terms of the hospital's
accreditation in general as I mentioned
we had our previous survey there were
opportunities for improvement but
nothing of immediate you know
significance or high level harm so we're
proud of those results
so in terms of the number of individuals
served again I just want to be mindful
of of the specific information that
might be helpful for this committee so
you can see on slide eight for fiscal
year 22 we had just under a thousand
Admissions and um just under again a
thousand discharges so
um you know we're trying to maintain
that healthy balance of admitting folks
who need our level of care into the
environment as well as discharging them
into the community when they're ready I
would like to pay attention to
um slide give me a second here
okay
thank you
um slide 17 thank you Brett so um it's a
it's more of a summary page but when
we're talking about Admissions and
discharges one of the things that we
briefly discussed at the prep meeting a
couple of weeks ago
um was the
um the wait list of course the Ed
waitlist that is of significance and
that we're trying to continue to admit
patients into New Hampshire hospital to
address but we also have
um at the end there you'll see on any
given day approximately 50 of patients
at New Hampshire hospital are considered
non-certified meaning that they don't
meet the criteria for a billable stay
and could be better served in a less
restrictive environment
so New Hampshire hospital works very
hard but of course as barriers that you
have heard from several others regarding
the ability to discharge into the
community and having those
community-based services and housing
opportunities has been a challenge for
us and as we understand is a challenge
throughout the state as well
I I don't remember if you were here when
I talked about this but I take a look at
the
sort of the stakeholder
bubbles chart that what what number is
that my fingers are not parsingly as
very well the all the stakeholders on
slide eight I believe population served
and and then and then when I when I'm
reading or listening to you talk about
what I'm thinking about is a is kind of
a different graphic that this data would
support and that's with New Hampshire
hospital kind of in the middle
and then the inputs being the statistics
like the inpatient wait list growing the
adult emergency room boarding you know
so that we can better see over time what
we're doing to uh to influence both as a
society and as you directly and everyone
else in between
trying to manage that and then on the
back end after New Hampshire hospital
all of the facilities where this 50
percent could go if they were available
because I I think I mentioned it to you
I maybe mentioned it to Mr Williams who
I don't see but but I I'm toying with
the idea that we ought to legislatively
change your mission statement to include
the explicit management and Reporting on
this this Ed to the community workflow
because there's no other organization in
the state it's better positioned to see
the whole problem and to provide maybe
recommendations and since that's not in
your mission statement
any Manpower or resources that you
allocate to that feels to me like it may
be borrowed and it's such a strategic
concern to the state I'm just wondering
if we need to do something
more substantive to better task you to
to to manage that and and so so what do
you think about that I I agree with you
and I appreciate your you know your big
picture perspective in that regard I can
say
um you know without getting into a lot
of detail that I know that there's some
work being done that I've been able to
participate in in DHHS similar to what
you're describing and trying to really
have better
um oversight and
um you know systematic approach to the
system in its entirety as opposed to in
certain pieces
um and and I think you know we're on the
same page about needing to make sure
that that system is in place so that the
throughput throughout the the mental
health system is solid and strong
because at this point there are
challenges that are real and there are
patients that are in the middle of those
challenges that need our help so I
appreciate that so I wouldn't pretend
that by making you responsible for
creating this dashboard view of the
workflow the clinical flow that that
that that you would be expected to to
solve the problem but by having access
to the information and the mission to
advise on it that you that you could be
Central to the idea of coordinating
recommendations that that could be
pursued because you know as a legislator
I I know I need the department to come
to me to tell me here's a proposal for
some legislation here's a problem this
is how we'd fix it and so I I don't know
if if you feel empowered or chartered
enough to to take that sort of
initiative
and I would I would want you to or
somebody in the department to do that
comment
oh
so Dr Han how are you
how am I doing am I being polite to
everyone no you are you're taking all
the coaching very seriously
um
um thank you Marissa hen associate
commissioner and um I just appreciate
this conversation and how Ellen's
framing things I think I would just add
you know
looking at the Ed boarding list is one
key indicator we look at every day and
it's available publicly and it's it's a
huge Focus right now that said it's um
it's an incomplete part of the picture
when we think about the ways in which
the uh or I should say it's it's
necessary but an insufficient part of
the data that we want to analyze and see
improvement with when we think about all
the changes that have happened with the
10-year Mental Health Plan and all
that's happening in terms of what Ellen
explained around how do we prevent
people from coming into our emergency
settings our inpatient settings in the
first place and then how do we make sure
they have a place to go which in turn
becomes your new prevention there are an
array of key data points that are
important to that so well I appreciate
the desire to engage in this policy
matter I think
um let us think a bit more about some of
the ways and share with you more updates
you'll also be hearing from Hampstead
Hospital which has some you know me seen
as well some really exciting progress
they'll report on today relative to this
full Continuum so I would urge that we
as a department take on the
responsibility of analyzing and
responding to the data but I appreciate
the attention and the way that you're
trying to highlight our Dynamic
responsibility in that respect
well thank you for all that I I I I
guess at the end of the day I'm I'm
looking at it from my old military
mindset I want an individual accountable
for understanding the situation and uh
developing
scenarios to to deal with it and and
right now my sense isn't is that if
there's any one accountable individual
just one the closest we come to it is is
probably the commissioner but I don't
even think it's in her mission statement
to do this so so if we need to formalize
a statutory obligation to do this and
Empower an individual to oversee it and
coordinate it and communicate on it I
I'd be very open to that because I I
sort of feel like it's that big of a
problem and it's worth solving and and I
I would want to hear what how the
department would want to do that so far
I just look at NH the New Hampshire
hospital as sort of the the Cornerstone
to
stuff on both ends and maybe a place to
start with possibility and the
possibility of pinning the rows on them
as being accountable for such a
situational awareness I'll use the term
well I wish the behavioral health system
was such that one entity could take full
accountability but the nature of the
work not unlike the dynamic military
challenges that you sometimes reference
in your own experience there are no
silver bullets or single entities that
have full responsibilities so it's it's
only through the collaborative
approaches that we're going to be able
to
create the positive change so so my
suggestion again would be let's take the
the charge you're giving us which is
what can we bring back as policy
opportunities as Financial opportunities
and share with you what the needs are
but um but I just would argue that a
single point of data changed statutorily
is
um
could misdirect the focus to a sense
that one entity has responsibility when
this is going to take the entire State
working together
thank you
so you want to get back to wherever you
want to go sure so in terms of New
Hampshire hospital was there a question
questions I don't know if this is the
right time but in terms of the
the forensic Hospital operations you had
a 42 million dollar request which was
zeroed out in the governor's budget and
um can you talk at all about how that
impacts uh
um you know achieving your mission you
know what your thought is on on that
particular item in the budget thank you
for that question and the forensic
hospital was exactly where I was going
to go next so I appreciate the timing in
terms of the operating budget and the
decision at the governor's phase I'm
actually entirely comfortable with it
and the rationale behind that well not
maybe not entirely comfortable but the
rationale behind that is because given
the information that we've received on
the amount of time that the construction
of the forensic hospital is going to
take in the resource availability in the
current state of our country post you
know post covid
um is such that the amount of time
that's necessary to do the construction
we hope is going to fall directly in
line with the time frame in that we hope
to be able to be operational of the
forensic Hospital in mid to late 2025.
um you know
it'd be nice to have a bit of wiggle
room but in terms of the the timing of
all of this we're actually a bit
appreciative from a New Hampshire
hospital perspective to have additional
time to operationalize the safety and
the efficiency of the forensic Hospital
um yeah sure so so this would be
entirely new spending as an entirely out
of General funds and even if it affects
the biennium after this one
we we are anticipating that that it
would be a hundred percent General funds
um we we have looked for other funding
sources and will continue to do so
um and and as as Ellen indicated when we
originally submitted our agency request
uh a number of months ago now
um we weren't aware of the of when the
construction would be finalized but with
the next budget cycle um as Ellen was
was indicating that would give us enough
time to be able to get the budget
appropriated begin to hire staff begin
to train staff in advance of that
um and there there is an hb2 provision
in section 231 within hb2 and and that
that that that it it essentially makes
it very clear that um that the
department is unable to admit any
individuals to the forensic facility uh
during this biennium
um so but there's no there's no cost
associated with that particular
provision
but but the clarity on that is the
current facility in which we're using
them as the secure forensic Hospital
there's still going to be an operation
then still receiving patients you're
really talking about the new facility is
not going to be open but the current
methodology of managing these patients
will remain ongoing correct yes all
right representative Waller I just
wanted to know have have we Broken
Ground on the on the facility no not yet
um we're so very close to sending out
the request for proposal to bid for the
construction company and then of course
that has to follow through the process
and then get get approved once the
construction company is selected we hope
to be able to see that RFP go out in the
next handful of weeks
representative hole for a question how
big is that facility uh it's slated to
be 24 beds
okay okay and the answer to proceed
thank you any other questions specific
to New Hampshire hospital if not I was
going to transition to the path program
looks good great thank you so I'll
direct you to the slide deck that is
indicated
um for the path program path stands for
Philbrook adult transitional housing the
path program is approximately three
years old at this point so we're really
feeling very
um proud of the enhancements that
they've been able to make to the program
and and the stability and really
continuing to work on
um you know the transition of
individuals between New Hampshire
hospital and path it's a 16 bed program
that New Hampshire hospital worked on
developing and opening a couple of years
ago and
um at this point they have
um you know really one of the things
that is happening most currently is the
um attempt to really kind of broaden
their scope of services to meet to best
meet the needs of the New Hampshire
hospital population
um so I'll direct you to slide six and
that talks about what path does and what
path does not do so you can see that
path does provide transitional housing
some medication supervision therapeutic
services intensive case management and
discharge planning and coordination with
the cmhcs or the Community Mental Health
Centers what they don't do is inpatient
care that's of course New Hampshire
hospital they also don't do involuntary
admissions diagnostic services acute
Medical Services or Pediatric Care
um in the interest of time I'll jump us
forward to slide
um nine and that talks about the number
of positions that path has across three
shifts there's 35 positions thankfully
um path has been able to maintain
relative stability in terms of their
Staffing so that's been very helpful to
be able to continue the mission of that
program uh for the count I'm on slide 10
now for the calendar year ending in
December of 2022 you can see that path
had 21 Admissions and 33 discharges with
an average census of 14 patients I think
it's important to note the median length
of stay was around 112 days that's high
but I think it also speaks to the
challenges just as we've discussed
around New Hampshire hospital from a
discharge disposition perspective the
path Mission really is focused on
intense time management around getting
these folks discharged back into the
community and really helping them to
self-engage in what that process would
look like and helping provide them with
resources and transportation to be able
to see apartments and whatnot but really
that high length estate I think speaks
to the services and abilities in from a
community standpoint around allowing
these individuals to discharge back to
those locations representative Waller do
you have a question I do
um you were probably this is probably
the first time in all of the
presentations that we have heard that I
heard that any place had a stable
Workforce and I wanted to know what do
you attribute that to
I think it's a really great question and
if I'm being perfectly honest a good
portion of the path staff came from New
Hampshire hospital
and although that's exciting because it
was you know a continuity of care and it
was folks that really understood the
services and and mission of that program
it was you know difficult for a New
Hampshire hospital to lose those staff
members
and I have my two regular questions is
there anything in House Bill 2 and that
relate to
um either New Hampshire hospital or path
and where the prioritize needs that were
not addressed
Nathan's going to help me out with this
hang on one minute
sure so um we we already talked about
the uh the forensic uh the forensic
psychiatric hospital admissions
provision in section 231 we we did have
a number of prioritized needs around the
question of enhancements I think we've
talked about this before this has come
up in other areas where we have
positions and the existing labor grade
is not and the pay scale is not
sufficient uh to attract
um to attract employees to those
positions we go through a process with a
division of personnel where you have to
make a justification and then those are
submitted to the governor and executive
Council
um we we originally did submit those
prioritized needs however
um I know that there are ongoing
negotiations between between the the
union and the governor's office to
address that through that through that
process as as I understand it at this
point in time and I'm not sure whether
the division of personnel has come to
this committee to talk about the
reclassification initiative that I think
we've briefly touched on previously to
to try to address that uh systemically
so in House Bill 2 on page 89 there is a
section 282
it's about receiving facilities and I
wondered if you could talk a little bit
about that and then I'd like to know if
it would be possible that we have
someone from the hospital Association
also talk about this piece sure this is
people waiting in the emergency rooms
yep so so that is let me just catch up
with you here that is those are sections
282 283 and 284 and this requires
hospitals to have a certain number of
drf beds based on the hospital's side
size to provide services to involuntary
emergency admissions for those in Mental
Health crisis
so do you have any information now about
how many beds we have now and what what
this chain what this what this really
will mean how many additional beds we
will have
um so I don't think we have any specific
information at this point around what
additional beds this may relate to
however there are approximately 60 beds
designated receiving facility beds
outside of New Hampshire hospital that
could and are able to take involuntary
patients
and so with the with these sections of
House Bill 2 increase the number of beds
available or yes yes but we don't know
how by how many correct
okay thank you
I would like to know if we could have
someone from the hospital Association
speak to this section
all right um
in the questions that you asked
um we're we're trying to organize those
questions because we've had several on
our side and so if you want to
as you dump them over to the the
department if you just would copy Us in
so that we can help track because you're
asking great questions you just heard
them
well I I would like from the Department
maybe is what they how many additional
beds how many we have now how many
additional beds you would anticipate
this section these sections would
um provide
I don't personally have that information
but we're happy to take that back and
and get that answer for you
and Mr I always mispronounce his name uh
a-h-e-r-n I think was from the hospital
Association he was here just a moment
ago we could have just said oh are you
would he be willing in a moment to take
an impromptu question from
representative Wallner
all right
thank you
great and I will just add again Marissa
had an associate commissioner that we
are working on getting those numbers
um and obviously the the language is is
a collaboration with the with the
governor's office and so we need to work
with them to fully understand
um the intent
um and so uh so more to come but the key
point there is this is envisioned as a
partnership
um where as you just heard from Ellen
there's um the bulk of the drf beds are
and will be at New Hampshire hospital
um for these patients needing ieas but
by coming together in partnership with
other hospitals that's the intent of
that component language
do you want to continue sure I'd be
happy to are there any additional
questions about the path program that I
can answer for the committee
so I missed it um
we initially used
um some buildings that were on the
campus
are we are we still satisfied with the
buildings we have on campus are we
looking for additional space I I've just
forgotten what facilities we use sure so
thank you for the question so the path
program is based out of the Philbrook
building which is
um across the campus from New Hampshire
hospital and the transitional housing
component of that building is only a
portion of the of the Philbrook Building
New Hampshire hospital does have
occupancy in the remainder of that
building with several individuals that
don't need to be on site at New
Hampshire hospital but do need to be in
close proximity and those individuals
are our I.T folks our finance folks and
that's essentially because we're so
tight for space at New Hampshire
hospital that moving those individuals
into the Philbrook Building made a lot
of sense so in terms of additional space
we we always could use more but we're
satisfied at this point
seeing commissioner Weaver has some
experience in Facilities Management
maybe maybe we could find her and you
could ask but uh rep you have a question
go ahead
so the space that you're using for
administrative functions now that's at
the Philbrook Center if those functions
could go elsewhere would that fill book
space provide us with more residential
would we be able to have another program
similar to path
um
I think I'd have to we'd have to think
about that a little bit more it did
require funding for construction
um you know there there is occupancy
needs under their certification around
patient spaces needing windows and
access to corridors and whatnot I'm not
necessarily sure that the remainder of
that building's setup is conducive to
that but but I'm happy to take that back
and and try to think about that some
more great thank you
all right and I don't see any other wait
um
can we take a little bit of an interrupt
I think this is all consistent of Mr
eight I screw your name up every time
Ahern
okay could you come up and would you
accept a question from representative
Wallner she's interested in uh
I call it Ed warehousing there's a nicer
term for it
good afternoon for the record Steve
onnan the New Hampshire Hospital
Association
happy to respond to a question
thank you and thank you for taking a
question so I was looking at House Bill
2 and there is on page 89 section 282
and section 283 there's a considerable
amount of language here about
[Music]
um
hospitals and Hospital licensing and
hospitals
um
providing
designated receiving beds and I wanted
to know if your Association has looked
at these sections and
um
have you done any analysis of how many
how many beds this would provide
thank you for the question
um yes we have seen the language
obviously didn't have that before House
Bill 2 was released
um but we have seen that
um and do not believe that that is the
appropriate response um to require as a
condition of licensure
um I've searched the country and I don't
know that there is another state that
requires hospitals as a condition of
their license to operate designated
receiving facility beds but I haven't
I'm not sure that's an exhaustive search
but so far have not turned that up
um
you know
this is a challenge and a problem that
has existed for the better part of a
decade and it requires
investments in a whole host of areas not
just inpatient care we've heard a lot
about the Investments that are being
made across the system to ensure that
patients are able to get the right Care
at the right place at the right time but
mental health as most every other as
every other health care condition
um there is a Continuum sometimes we
treat people out here in the community
sometimes we treat them in the hospital
and as they move through that Continuum
it's very clear that we don't have
enough inpatient capacity The Proposal
that would that is in House Bill 2 that
would require every hospital to operate
a designated receiving facility that
depending on the number depending upon
their size
really makes very little sense from an
operational perspective you know we've
heard about the Staffing challenges that
exist at New Hampshire hospital they
exist all across the state
um in in hospitals and Healthcare
settings
if every hospital small hospital had to
have two beds or four beds where would
they find those health care workers to
staff those beds
you know we often hear that private
hospitals are able to pay more than the
state hospital so those employees tend
to move where they can
my concern is that you know we're going
to be robbing Peter to pay Paul to
staff all of these these new units which
again is is not what we need to be doing
we just heard that uh you know there are
two units that are now closed those
units from my perspective need to be
open
um you know I understand the challenge
of Staffing units using Travelers and
the rest the hospitals across the state
are doing that every day to meet the
needs of the patients that they're
seeing and we need to do that the
proposal in House Bill 2 is not the
answer we have been and continue to be
willing to sit down and work through
this to resolve these issues but again
this is not the the appropriate response
and we certainly have very big concerns
about that
thank you I my second part of my
question was have you done any analysis
with the hospitals about has anyone
figured out exactly how many beds this
would provide
um we're working through that and my
sense is it's probably somewhere North
close to 100 additional beds but that's
uh we're continuing to work through that
again my my view is that's not the the
appropriate response
um and uh we don't believe we should be
moving in that direction and are you
working with
um New Hampshire hospitals Health and
Human Services the governor's office to
come up with what would be a solution as
you know
um there is litigation that's ongoing
and those conversations are occurring uh
in that uh in that venue
um so we'll continue to to have those
conversations at the highest levels that
we can to try and find a resolution I
guess the other piece that you didn't
mention that was in a house bill too is
a provision that would remove the
requirement that patients in an acute
psychiatric crisis that are subject to
an iea an involuntary emergency
admission are to be transported
immediately to the appropriate location
to receive the care and due process that
they need and deserve and frankly are
entitled to under law this would remove
that and instead of saying immediately
we would transport patients as soon as a
bat is available that is simply wrong
enshrining the current system which is
failing patients is not the right answer
and we should not be moving in that
direction
thank you
so um just I'm just looking for clarity
there are two specific sections 282 and
283 and I understand your association's
position is that you just oppose both of
them yes
um and that you're working with
relevant people around the court order
response to and and so there may be some
solution or recommendation we could see
in two three four weeks maybe uh correct
okay
are there
representative thank you thank you for
taking my question
um it wasn't until this weekend when I
was reviewing this section that I I'm
from Nashua so I have two very large
hospitals in my city that there were
hospitals with fewer than 25 beds
um can you just give me an idea of how
many of those small local hospitals were
talking about and so and just a quick
follow-up to that how many beds do they
have now that could receive these
patients
um so there are 31 hospitals in the
state of New Hampshire 26 of which are
acute care hospitals we have five
specialty Rehabilitation hospitals
including New Hampshire hospital and
Hampstead um but the 26
um hospitals 13 50 of them are small
rural hospitals they are called critical
access hospitals that's a designation
from the federal government under the
Medicare program that limits their
capacity to 25 beds so they are
traditionally in the you know Northern
Western uh you know reaches of the state
and the rural communities they have all
but um one has 25 beds um as acute care
beds
um upper Connecticut Valley Hospital and
Colebrook has fewer I believe
they're staffed for 12. there are
hospitals so Franklin Regional Hospital
has a designated receiving facility they
have 10 beds that are allocated for that
um I don't know that they're able to
always fully staff and serve 10 patients
at a time sometimes it's Staffing
sometimes it's because of a mix of
patients and the the facility that they
have because they have to double they
have to book more than one patient in
the room sometimes you can't put two
people in the same room and then Cottage
Hospital in Woodsville has a 10 bed gero
psych unit it's not a designated
receiving facility bed so all of those
exist around the state thank you for
that I just wanted to point out that
requiring two beds out of ten is would
probably be devastating yeah two beds
out of the out of the potential 25 or
the 10 of the the designated receiving
facility so uh as I understand the
proposal
um Franklin Regional Hospital uh would
not have to add additional capacity
because they already have
um those 10 beds it would only be those
hospitals that do not have that capacity
yet today thank you very much
it shows a former guy who used to think
I knew something about hospitals is is
it is is it your position that
by requiring you to open up any kind of
a new bed in an environment where we
have essentially fixed Manpower you
would have to rob Peter to pay Paul to
open up any different kind of bed and as
a result this would be sort of
dysfunctional in the way of forcing you
to make clinical decisions that may not
be appropriate for your location well
again you would have to have to staff
those units with the appropriate staff
so to be able to make those clinical
decisions I guess my point was you know
my My worry is that you know we have a
staffing challenge at New Hampshire
hospital today and at Hampstead this
could only exacerbate that challenge and
ultimately end up having fewer fewer
beds less capacity at New Hampshire
hospital in Hampstead than we do today
I think I'm going to record that in my
head as a yes but
um are there are there any other
questions I really appreciate you coming
up and taking impromptu questions from
us always happy thank you yeah uh thank
you and and to representative tolerski
there is a really great graphic that the
association publishes it's about a foot
wide and maybe 18 inches long that's got
nice colors with the map that shows all
of the
hospitals by type and category it's just
a beautiful thing I hang it on my wall
and it may be that there's a lobbyist
here who could get you one of those
great graphics
I I I opened that one just a couple days
ago and it's a beautiful graphic and
great information so thank you
okay so I think we interrupted our path
discussion did we interrupt it or had we
just uh ended it abruptly
there's no more questions about the path
program I'm happy to move on to the
Glencliff information
any other questions on path
all right so Glenn Cliff it is
okay so you'll see
um in the Glenn Cliff slide deck
um of course their mission and vision
statement at the beginning
their accounting units a little bit of
history
and some overview one of the things that
we didn't point out in the previous
slides is the delivery system so I just
want to make a point to mention slide
seven because that is redundant in a
couple of the other presentations just
so you know where everyone fits
um in terms of the services that Glenn
Cliff provides they are they service
residents that have a medical need that
require the long-term level of care and
have a mental illness or developmental
disability and haven't been able to have
their needs met by other providers so it
tends to be that a decent portion of the
admissions that Glenn Cliff receives are
individuals from New Hampshire hospital
and we work collaboratively
collaboratively with them in trying to
get those individuals moved at a time
that's appropriate you can see in the
slide deck the different level of
services that they provide
and they do strive to use non-medication
modalities and alternative approaches as
well as their training their staff in
behavioral interventions to try to meet
the individual residents needs on slide
10 you can see their census and it takes
you through from fiscal year 18 all the
way to fiscal year 23. they did have a
budgeted census of 116.
um you can see more recently that their
current census has declined and
unfortunately as has been a common theme
they are experiencing Staffing concerns
that resulted in the need to have a
lower maintain a lower census
um glencliffe home does also have a wait
list that that wait list did grow
through the pandemic and again you know
due to Staffing challenges that wait
list
um remains relatively high you can see
that in January of 2023 it's right
around the 40 mark they're about 15
individuals as they understand currently
at New Hampshire hospital that are also
on that weight so where are these 41
these 41 aren't in emergency rooms where
no there there's maybe a small number
might be but but most of them are
elsewhere correct okay where is the
elsewhere uh New Hampshire hospital for
one other nursing homes refer
individuals to Glenn Cliff there are
times to I know Todd's here in the
audience
um he's well you're welcome to come up
Todd if you have more information but
there are times that hospitals do make
referrals to Glenn Cliff but in order to
be able eligible to be at Glen Cliff
they have to be deferred by other three
other nursing facilities in advance of
that how'd I do Todd
for the record my name is Todd Bickford
I'm the executive director of glencliffe
home
um and Alan pretty much had it there a
majority of folks out of that 41 15 of
them are currently at New Hampshire
hospital
um off the top of my head about 12 of
them are at other nursing homes so what
occasionally happens is somebody is
living in the community they need
long-term care services they go to a
nursing home and then that nursing home
finds that they can't meet the
behavioral needs or the mental health
needs that are on top of the medical
needs we do have a few people that are
still at home their loved ones are
taking care of them but it's becoming a
struggle a theme we often see is loved
one is taking care of them but now the
loved one is also in their 80s and now
dealing with somebody that has medical
issues and behavioral mental health
issues on top of it so it becomes too
challenging and then we do have a number
of folks that are at other hospitals not
in the Ed but they are waiting for
placement with us
you you're not the the gentleman that
presented to us two years ago are you
probably am oh you are okay at the time
I asked if we could get a site visit and
because we were in the pandemic it was
just not we couldn't execute on that and
you said after the pandemic we could
probably arrange something can we could
could we start to plan on a glen Cliff
Day absolutely I would I would love to
have everybody come for a tour because I
I it just helps me to see something to
walk the ground and stuff I'm also very
Visual and it's a an incredible campus a
lot of history so I love showing it off
so I'd love to arrange that we did it
about four years ago we got a couple of
uh 15 passenger vans from New Hampshire
hospital and brought up a bunch of folks
most of them were from the capitol
committee but I would be more than glad
to have all of you come up for a tour
okay and so you're you're you're you're
you're we're not going to be able to do
anything until after March for sure but
um
so you have a campus with old
established buildings so your
maintenance costs are probably Rising
more rapidly than they would be if these
were newer buildings what kind of a
maintenance problem are we facing
um that's a complex question but in
general
um most of the maintenance that the
buildings need again we're a very large
campus we're about 70 Acres we have 22
buildings 20 of them are being used
because I I heard your questions earlier
about facilities uh two two are
mothballed
but we have been fortunate over the last
couple decades of getting a lot of
capital projects so the main resident
buildings which is the Brown building
which has two units in the Lamont
building which has two units has
received a lot of updates in the last 12
15 years we've done the roof we've done
the windows we've done asbestos
abatement so as all those TV shows say
it has really good bones so it's mostly
aesthetic type maintenance that needs to
be done except for our sewage system
which we hopefully will be addressing in
the next biennium and then some things
like we're all Steam Heat so a lot of
the steam traps need to be replaced but
those are all projects that we can
manage throughout the next couple
bienniums
so are those items in your hb1 request
are they in the capital budget do you
know maybe that's uh so we we had
originally submitted in our prioritized
need during the agency phase the the
waste water replacement
um we present we also submitted that
within our capital budget and we
presented to the capital budget earlier
uh committee earlier this week for the
house
um and we'll be we'll be talking with
them next Monday about
um about closing out some existing
capital budget projects to find funding
to replace the Wastewater system so that
was that was included in our original PN
um and it's you you won't see an
additional request here because we're
handling that through the capital budget
process
do you have a follow-up
you want to ask about hb2 are there any
hp2 items in here are there any hv2
items in here
um not well in here yes uh I yes
um so we we did include two prioritize
needs um one for each state fiscal year
24 and 25
1.1 million dollars of General funds and
that is to cover uh what would
um Todd's team has has identified to be
a projected Surplus we uh expect a
similar
um or not Surplus deficit we expect a
similar deficit to occur this year that
we'll try to cover Through transfers
um through the through the year-end
closed process but I will be submitting
those those requests um to to Kevin uh
probably later this evening
all right thank you I think I think you
were at the wait list when we took the
side tour if I could just add quickly
um again glad to have everybody come up
for an official tour but on the 25th of
March we are having our annual sugar off
party so because we still maintain
making our own maple syrup so fresh
donuts and maple syrup so if anybody
wants to come to that it's a 10-1
horse-drawn wagon and everything it's a
lot of fun you know if we finish our
budget work then that could be a reward
maybe you know a sweet reward thank you
thank you Todd
um and I will just add that Todd gives a
phenomenal tour it's a beautiful campus
and really a sight to see
um their self-sustained environment up
there and I would also just take a
minute to add that any of the 24 7
facilities of DHHS we're happy to give
anyone a tour and invite you to come
we've started working together a little
bit more systematically as the 24 7
leaders of the different facilities
throughout DHHS and have kind of
established somewhat of a committee so
one of the agenda items on that
committee is to really welcome
individuals such as yourselves to come
to the facilities and really understand
more about what we do
so the last time representative Weiler
and I took a tour of the New Hampshire
hospital we couldn't go into the
building and so we were marched around
the perimeter of the building and the
cold and the wet and and I thought wow
this is a really warm welcome but no but
it was enough to see the problem that
you had with the wetlands and building
in the wetlands so I I'd be happy to
schedule one of those for the New
Hampshire hospital too sure that'd be
great we'd welcome you to come uh
represent walner
yes I noticed in the other presentations
that you did New Hampshire hospital
and path I think also you had a daily
rate
and do we have do you have that in the
Glenn Close Flags I'm sorry it might be
here and I just didn't see it
toddler Kevin can you can I invite you
up
I apologize that that wasn't in your
presentation our current daily rate for
Medicaid is
378.78 and our private pay rate is
427.60 a day
great thank you could you please repeat
uh Medicaid rate Medicaid rate was
378.78 and the private pay rate is
427.60
I would like to just point out though
that um as a state agency we only
collect half of that rate because we
only collect the federal portion of the
Medicaid we do not collect the state
portion
thank you
I I just whoever put slide 12 in here
I I think of all of the presentations of
all of the slides this comes this may be
my very favorite one because it's really
the first one that I recall seeing what
sort of Manpower benchmarks are being
used to identify how much Manpower you
need and and it it it at least starts
that conversation in a very nice way
um it could it could it could come to
the conclusion to say exactly how many
are Justified you know but but but I
love this slide Mr White if if we
someday ended up with something like
this for multiple agencies that would be
great
I think thank you Mr chair and I if I
could just take a minute to elaborate on
that
um some of my history prior to coming to
New Hampshire hospital is in long-term
care but I'm gonna defer to Todd if I
get it wrong
um in that nursing facilities across the
country who fall under CMS which of
course glencliffe would um in terms of
the fact that they receive federal funds
nursing facilities fall into this CMS
rating program they have to have to
participate in this to be able to be
affiliated with CMS so
um it's it's something that is on a
national level and as you indicated
really gives as clear of a picture
around what national standards are and
really where facilities fall within
those national standards so I appreciate
I appreciate your comments about it
I I don't unless there's additional
questions about Glenn Cliff that we
haven't addressed
curious on slide 14
um the 95.7 percent received the covet
injection
um why isn't that a hundred or you know
what what what's driving that
our residents have the
um right to refuse
um so we have a handful of residents
that have declined getting the
vaccination
by declining to refuse do they get a
different standard of care in any way
not at all
good
all right uh what's next
I think we're ready for Hampstead
and thanks for coming
I'm really slow
they have the right to refuse but these
are like seriously
um
these are really serious patients in
terms of their mental capacity and I and
I just wonder I'm getting more curious
about the extent to which they're
capable of making a decision to have the
injection or not
so I it tends to be too that there's a
guardian involvement with several of
these individuals and if they have
guardianship over the person
um those Guardians might be the ones
making the decision on behalf of those
residents okay on us kind of related
question
uh how how does glencliffe handle
absentee ballots do these patients
receive absentee ballots uh in group or
individual request or in some other way
thank you for that question um it's
changed over the I've been at glencliffe
for 22 years we used to take all the
residents that were interested in voting
and we would we would drive them to the
town of Benton Town Hall which I don't
know if you're familiar with town of
Benton but it's like a population of 48
and it's on the other side of the
mountain and literally you can't get
there from glencliffe you have to drive
around throughout the towns about eight
years ago we worked with the town folks
and we now have set up a little voting
station at Glencliff and the residents
that want to vote can go vote
independently there so they it's
technically absentee balance but it's
monitored in um in conjunction with the
town so it's kind of a hybrid are they
generally aware enough of what's going
on to be able to cast an informed ballot
and I know that's not the standard that
anyone can cast a ballot without any
kind of a competency test so I'm not
asking a legal question I'm asking just
a real world question
or do they know what they're doing
the majority of residents that choose to
vote do and some are very active
politically
they say on top of the news
honestly we have a handful or two that
you know especially when you're talking
about somebody that suffers from
paranoid schizophrenic who may have
interesting choices when they vote but
they vote
will eventually be proven right anyway
so
these days you never know yeah all right
uh and then to what extent does your
staff support them when they're voting
other than physically helping them get
into a booth and those type of things
they vote on their own our staff are
very diligent about not trying to
influence in One Direction or the other
staying as neutral as possible fantastic
thank you
we're back to Hampstead thank you
good afternoon I'm Kathy Collins I'm the
CEO of Hampstead Hospital and I have
Sean qualter the CFO
hello I'm John qualter the CFO at
Hampstead Hospital
so following in Ellen's footsteps was
good because now I know we can skip over
the things we already talked about in
the previous pre uh hearing so we will
skip over to slide number four
which brings us to our ftes
um
and as you know from our previous
Hampstead is state owned but is run
clinically by a third party vendor
so we have 27 DHHS positions 27 ftes
at Hampstead but we have 185 that ftes
that fall under the third party vendor
contract
so part of our key accomplishments that
I wanted to review
number one was last we were here we were
talking about our wait list and our goal
for getting our wait list and I'm happy
to say that today our wait list is zero
so that was a very big accomplishment
for us today so it didn't make it in the
slides because it didn't happen until
today
um what what's the key reason for
hitting zero the diminished demand
increased Manpower letting you open new
beds what was the key factor
um you'll see actually in the slides
that we've been able to increase our
capacity and our beds but that coupled
with I think the system is just really
working the way it's supposed to be
right now with children's system of care
and we're actually able to treat the
children we're starting to see once we
get them out of the emergency rooms and
into lower levels of care that we've
been working on
not as many people are actually needing
the beds 100
it's also school vacation week in New
Hampshire last week so there is a little
bit less demand but we have been able to
open up more beds on a general
day-to-day basis so so is it accurate
then to assume that your weight list of
zero means that we have no kids in an
emergency room in New Hampshire being
boarded waiting a bed
as of this morning there were zero
patients waiting for a bed at Hampstead
in an emergency room which is a slightly
different answer than my question does
that mean there are no kids in an
emergency room anywhere
needing a bed
I could only answer if there's a
referral to Hampstead so so you're not
omnipotent I'm not okay all right sorry
no I just I I just it's such a tragic
thing to have people stuck in the
emergency rooms waiting for care and
it's particular heinous when it's kids
so go ahead so in terms of our current
wait list for the State of New Hampshire
Hampstead Hospital is the only facility
providing this type of psychiatric care
and the vast majority of these kids are
voluntary patients as opposed to the
ieas which which Hampstead in the past
has also been able to accommodate so I
guess I want to give that added
um credit where it's due that in fact
the the wait list is in fact a zero
meaning while there could be patients
with other needs that are being met by
other providers uh the wait list and the
Ed boarding as it's understood for kids
is is specifically a Hampstead only list
representative hole
thank you
um and maybe this is I'm not sure who
the right person is so hey there doctor
and it's an understanding of when is an
iea the right course of action I know
it's not budget related but I'm trying
to understand how that impacts the
number of children right in particular
and what are the safeguards that exist
right
can that process be abused not abused
um I saw in one of the notes in one of
the slides that we're talking about
um people going I think this was the
adult section right by who have been
adjudicated
um Not Guilty by reason of insanity
that's a very different standard so help
me as someone who's new to all of this
understand that whole process and are
you asking about ieas in general or
specific to children
General as a process overall specific to
children as it impacts that population
the most okay so I think why doesn't
Kathy start with her explanation and we
may want to call on Ellen for some
additional insight there on the point so
I'll let them take it thanks
all right so as far as with children the
number one criteria it for an iea is
that they're a danger to themselves or
others and that they're in need of care
the patients under 18 are not eligible
or competent to make a decision about
their care and therefore they have a
guardian a parent that would make that
determination so as long as they are
voluntary by Guardian they would be able
to be non-i8 and receive voluntary
Services provided the guardian is is
willing to sign them in
so what happens when there's a conflict
between let's say child protective
services and the parents are Guardians
relative to this child's in a hospital
and someone is offering I want I want to
keep the child there under an iea just I
want to understand what safeguards are
in place on both sides
so the if an iea petition if a parent is
not willing or a guardian not willing to
sign a patient in that a provider deems
needs that level of care then an iea
petition would be filed and we would
follow the normal procedure
through the court process through the
court process thank you
did you need more clarification from
Ellen
I think for now that answers it okay
okay all right so moving forward
um obviously our key accomplishment is
we're in month nine of State ownership
and that in and of itself has been a big
lift to get us over that hump from
private to State ownership
we developed our new Mission Vision
Values we also have
joined in collaboration with the
integrated system of care to improve the
identification of appropriate levels of
care for children in the state of New
Hampshire to try to serve them at the
need at the needed level that they they
um require
um next question about that
we've probably seen or heard something
in this division about the hhrtf could
you could you just spend like 10 seconds
telling us what that acronym is and then
I get curious anytime I see a broad
organization I wonder about it's
organizational competency is it is it
actually able to be effective
so if you could tell us what it is and
tell us about its effectiveness
I'm going to answer your first part
first and it's Hampstead Hospital and
residential treatment facility that's
what hhrtf stands for
and then your second question I'm going
to ask for some clarification so I'm
gonna I'm gonna amend my first question
then
so that's Hampstead Hospital
collaborating with an integrated system
of care
is that an entity or is that a concept
it's a concept it's the children's
system of care throughout the state of
New Hampshire which includes dcyf and
Children's Bureau of Mental Health
so is that collaboration
so so that's a little amorphous right
just naturally because it's the entire
integrated system of care
and and and and again we don't have
accountability and control of that
system of care so I'm I just get curious
whether or not we're able to
be effectively effective collaborators
with something that's not
well established or well defined
this is a new collaboration for
Hampstead Hospital
because we were not part of that system
of care so we were working outside of
the the walls if you will of that
construct before and now we are able to
be part of that system so that we
actually can impact and have more of
discussion and collaboration to be sure
that we're able to find the right bed or
the right services for a child
representative Wallner
so I'm curious about something
um I think Hampstead Hospital might be
the first
place that New Hampshire has had a
situation where we have the
administration of the hospital or the
service being provided is with state
employees and then there's a contract
for the actual care and I'm interested
one and how that you think that's
working how long is the contract with
well well path
um
as a model I'm just interested in
whether or not it's something that
might
be looked at in other areas are there
advantages are what are the
disadvantages
yeah absolutely so we
um collaborate we're lucky in this
contract that the executive director for
the well path is a long-standing was the
director of nursing for Hampstead
Hospital as well so there is some
longevity on that side as well to
partner the
Department actually oversees all aspects
of the contract
and it doesn't go without its challenges
of course
to oversee any contract but we have a
very good working relationship and we
are working out any you know issues with
delivery of Care Systems and things like
that we meet our executive team is
actually comprised of the well path
Recovery Solutions we are pretty much
half and half between DHHS leadership
and well path Recovery Solutions I it is
a larger scale model of what happens at
New Hampshire hospital
they have a contract for their providers
and so it is it is definitely something
that that works we're able to impact on
different levels the
attraction of staff so to speak that is
not as big of an issue as it is with
State entities because there's a little
bit more flexibility with that
and and just to to further answer your
question representative walner
um so back in in 2022 when the when the
state acquired Hampstead Hospital we had
entered into a two-year sole source
contract with Hampstead Outlook Inc
um and and we have been working on and
and we told the executive council at the
time when we brought that forward I
believe we told the fiscal committee as
well that when we brought that forward
we would be going back out to Bid And so
we've already we're well into the the
RFP development process so that we make
sure that many months prior to that
contract expiring that we already have a
signed contract with um with whether
it's Hampstead if they win or it's
another party that with that wins based
on the objective criteria that we
include within that procurement
okay
I have one one more question so
um the workforce
um that well well path their employees
are are they unionized
they're in the process of
um negotiating a Union contract yes
thank you
representative stream uh kind of a
budgetary question I mean obviously this
is only nine months I would expect
maybe more variability going forward in
the results in this than maybe other
budget items and especially with such a
substantial portion of the budget is
this I think one contract right so and
uh and that that that contract I think
you said uh were were you know roughly
halfway through the two-year contract
the second second uh the renewal will
kick in
um you know a year and three months from
now
um and
um I I guess I'm kind of interested in
your in in your perspective on how much
variability we might expect in
performance
um or financial performance or need in
this group
sure so I'll I'll take it from from the
finance angle and then I'll and then
I'll hand it over to Kathy
um so we actually don't we don't have
any renewals within that contract it's
it's it's a two-year sole source and so
we will be going out to bid
um the the Hampstead budget is on page
1092 the governor's recommended budget
um the big the big class line is is the
um where we have a it's about
approximately 27 million dollar
contract and as as Kathy had indicated
it is a slightly different not slightly
it's a different model than the New
Hampshire hospital
um we and and Sean has been working
um on on looking at the expense at
looking at the expenses as we go forward
looking at the revenues that we're
bringing in
um in the governor's recommended budget
uh we we did have a reduction of four
and a half million dollars in general
funds from the agency budget in the
current current biennium the they're
roughly nine million dollars there that
we're asking for General funds in 24
that's covered through arpa funds
um and and I my plan was to submit to
the committee an analysis of our
revenues versus our expenses to date
because we do we do receive third-party
revenues and it's always our objective
to maximize those as much as we can but
we do you know we we do have some risk
there and we are also taking a closer
look at each of the class lines that
were originally based upon New Hampshire
hospitals budget and their spend and we
are seeing some variation there so so my
plan was to follow up with the committee
to provide that analysis to now that we
have a few more months of information to
to go to go on uh to try to get us to um
uh I guess I'll dub the a happier place
so to speak when it when it comes to our
revenues and our expenditures
and and when would that update be and
would that be part of this process that
we're in now
um I would hope to have that to you by
the end of the week okay
um and this would affect this but may go
back to Glen Cliff as well because I I
thought he um I thought I heard that you
know some money comes from the federal
government directly to glencliffe maybe
that's some of the the money that comes
in here but we don't see on the budget
items federal funds uh for either of
these two facilities but apparently
there are federal funds and if if this
went
um
um if if the services went away there
actually would be reduction in money
going to um to those facilities and
hence the state since we own them do I
understand that correctly yep so on on
page uh 1093 the budget you have the
transfer from other agencies lines uh
those are our dish funds those are the
funds that we receive it's actually a
transfer uh from the Medicaid budget to
cover uncompensated care costs the the
agency income uh those are the the
patient revenues and Sean and Kathy can
certainly elaborate further on those and
then the general fund uh amount there
that's consistent with the budget that
we had put forth for this biennium only
it is no longer arpa funds it is now
General funds as those are profunds
won't be available in the future
um
okay and that 20 20 million in agency
income that's from
from who what kind of organizations do
you want to Leverage
would be a common Revenue received from
uh Managed Care organizations and uh
private payers thank you
other questions
all right
so the next phase that we're looking at
is our interagency development of our
prtf which will be the first psychiatric
Residential Treatment Facility in the
state of New Hampshire for level five
Residential Care
the program development for that is
completed and the construction for that
is beginning and we are intending to go
live with that program
in 2023
as we move forward as everyone else has
spoken our key challenges are our
Workforce challenges we have a 49
counselor vacancy rate for our Direct
Care and 38 for our nurses
uh but we have seen significant
increases though in our ability to
recruit for those positions which has
allowed those additional beds from the
last time that we were here
the other key challenges is the
increased need for mental health
services that we've all seen post
pandemic and during the pandemic
and then also the other challenge that
Hampstead is has is the key
infrastructure and network
infrastructure and systems is we had
none I think we talked last time I have
we're a paper and we are still paper and
we're moving hopefully towards more of
an electronic ability to
document so I've thought about that and
most institutions have moved to an EHR
because Medicare
held out money for them to have
incentives for doing it
what what is your incentive to move out
of paper into digital is is there a
money issue is there a productivity
issue is it just because issue I mean
what what's your motivation
I think it's coordination of care is
really the number one
driver for more efficient ability to be
able to document and to be able to have
records
follow patients across a continuum
financially I'd have to defer to Nathan
well I I think one um one important
thing just to point out here is we we
did submit a request for electronic
health records systems
um to to address the issue at all of our
24 7 facilities the governor included
that in his recommended capital budget
and we spoke to the capital budget
committee on Monday about that request
to try to create and I'm not going to
pretend to sound intelligent when it
comes to I.T systems but to try to
create a more synthesized system that
can speak across the 24 7 facility so
we're not having to build out five
separate systems we can create a unified
system and and day readers can certainly
speak to that
all right excellent so I just wanted to
draw your attention to slide number
eight uh page eight
this is just the representation of the
populations that we've served the number
of patients that we've served we gave
you a full year look back so there you
have six months of pre-state owned
there as well but as a total we've
served a 1052
children and and adults in the state
we also on the next slide you'll see our
average census
that actually you can see how that
correlates that our average census for
each month we're actually seeing that
upper trajectory that goes along with
our increased Recruitment and onboarding
of additional staff
on slide 10. so that doesn't make sense
to me I'm sure it makes sense it just
didn't make sense to me I your weight as
you're adding staff
I don't understand the correlation of
why adding an onboarding staff would
increase the wait list are you I would
think this is the census sorry this is
the census
so these are these are the patients that
are in the hospital oh so I was looking
at the title average census and wait
list and so I assumed the numbers were
weightless yeah sorry nope they had I
apologize
um that information didn't make it onto
the slide the waitlist piece okay
representative Waller
I was having the same problem with it I
couldn't understand how you add census
and weightless together nope sorry I
apologize the title of the slide shut up
it's okay it's just making sure we're
paying attention I it's a it's a gimmick
I get it uh representative hole I think
we passed the test on that one um
question back on slide eight
you sum up the numbers in both the
pre-state owned and the state-owned but
are any of those the same person between
the first six months or is this based on
either people coming into the facility
or leaving the facility how are you
tracking the numbers yep yep these are
all individuals served uh Unique
Individuals served
and then the last slide that I have for
you is just our average Admissions and
discharges by month I know we talked
previously and I wanted to show
um that we had seen that our admissions
our discharges and admissions were
disproportionate and we wanted to be
able to show that they we are actually
able to see an increase of admissions
average admissions per day based again
on being able to increase the census
is this is this a normal ratio for for
your client base I it it feels like in
February we've got about 10 percent
turnover on your census per month
that feels slow to me from my
understanding of healthcare but this is
a different population is this is this
normal
yes these are these are our admissions
and discharges in average just in
relation to each other but our average
length of stay is around 10 days we did
see a significant increase in that over
during the pandemic but we are starting
to see that average length of stay start
to come down to an average of 10.
all right so it's just me having trouble
with the visual information I think but
okay thank you any questions anyone
go ahead
please remind me what what is if you
have we're fully if everyone was fully
staffed
um what would be your sin what would you
um how many patients would you be able
to care for yeah our maximum inpatient
capacity currently is 55. we do have the
one unit that is closed it is being
renovated with Behavioral Health
Furniture the opposite actually of what
Ellen was doing we're trying to turn
ours into more kid-friendly because that
was our adult unit
so once that unit is on um is on open it
would actually give us 70 the ability
for 70 inpatient beds and then with the
opening of the prtf that will be 12 beds
so
with the contract
is the contractor is having they're
having
um Staffing issues also is that correct
so as they are not able to staff
you're not able to
bring in more children is there any
flexibility within the contract I mean
if these were state employees you
wouldn't be you would you would have
empty positions
is there any flexibility when they can't
staff to the maximum
yes
yep so the as far as our costs and
expenditures are directly proportionate
to our census so as we are able to
increase and we have the Staffing then
those beds are staffed if we don't have
the staff available then the census is
capped at what we do have this these
staff for so the costs are directly
proportionate
thank you
any other questions representative
norgren
so you have
regular staff but then you also have the
extra staff that comes in from outside
is that right or are all these staff
members
sorry we have um all the staff currently
we do not have any agency staff
currently
thank you
if if I if I may just kind of add to
that
um if you do look at the budget on 1092
um the the class 12 that you see here
these are those six unclassified
positions that I think we talked about
last time and then what you'll see
you'll see the class 59 on 1093 these
are the temporary full-time positions
um I I will be making a request for the
committee to consider
um to to take the class 59 and move it
to class 10 so that they would be
permanent authorized positions we used
Class 59 through the fiscal process
um when when this data acquired
Hempstead hospital because we weren't
able to establish permanent authorized
positions there but these 21 state
employees
um they they uh we're requesting that
they become just kind of permanent of
the permanent budget structure
so do you already have a feeling or a
knowledge of what you think your total
full-time permanent
head count request is going to be for
the Department
um it will be the exact same number that
is currently in class uh 50 oh the
department for the Department in total
because last last budget I think it was
around 3124 and I'm just curious where
you think you're going to end up
sure so
um you can do that later I just I just
thought I'd ask you since it seemed like
you may have had the number with you I I
if I remember correctly I I think in the
governor's recommended budget I think it
was 3213 so it'd be adding the the 21 on
top of that so it was 200 300 or sorry
3230 and throughout the department
that's the only ad you think you're
gonna make I recommend or ask we have
the three requests the three position
requests from
um the uh the commissioner for
facilities earlier today but otherwise
um
no we won't have any more position
requests at this point okay are there
other questions here
do you have any
parting thoughts for us any summary we
we didn't bounce you around nearly as
much as the other people
representative hole you have a question
I do so of the
positions and change I guess how many of
those are currently unfilled in
theoretically would not be filled in the
near time given the the current hiring
climate
so last I had checked
um I think we were at
19.6 vacancy rate
um again the the challenge that you
you've probably you've heard me refer to
earlier was
um I I basically had to instruct each
division area based I was a proportion
of their General funds uh for this
biennium that they had to hold several
hundred thousand or for New Hampshire
hospital had to hold north of three
million dollars in Personnel costs and
so you know as we've kind of talked
throughout this process some of our
positions are 50 50 some are 60 30 so to
get to 100 of General funds you may have
to hold two positions vacant or you may
have to hold more than that so several
hundred of the positions that we have
today we've never even had the
opportunity to put out to to to post and
and I know we talked about why don't you
put them all out and then move the money
around which makes a lot of sense to me
but there is a tremendous amount of
um uh administrative work and system
restrictions that that don't assault
that don't necessarily allow us to be
that Nimble
um so I don't have a I don't have a
crystal ball answer to your question I
think it's a good one
um but but those are just some just some
of the challenges that I want to point
out thank you of course
so when you refer to system in
flexibility
are you referring to the it system
itself is not a very robust are you
saying that the the procedures that
we've wrapped around that system are are
not very flexible
part of its system part of its rules
part of it's uh just process I I think
there's a variety of components there
are solutions that are in place say for
um like like our dcyf field staff we'll
do Mass postings there so you know even
if we have like 50 vacant positions or
something like that not all of them
funded we'll still we'll utilize those
tools that are available to us but in
certain cases like if I if I have if I
have an area that has
um like a very specific position
um that is very different from the
others I think like Medicaid is a good
example of this where they have they
have Specialists I I have to make a
choice do I post this Specialist or do I
post this this specialist because we
follow a process where we have to find
the funds tie them to the position and
the system you know before we go out to
post it's it's similar to
um you know I can't enter into a
contract without being able to encumber
the funds within the accounting system
it's kind of the same principle
so if there was just some flexibility
for you to open multiple positions even
though you have less in the bank than
you would need you still can't do that
because of administrative rules or
because of the way the it systems are
connected
it's I.T systems it's rules its existing
procedures and at the end of the day too
it's just it's resources to have the to
to have the folks you know to be able to
follow those processes all the way
through okay representative walner did
you have a question
I have two questions I have the one the
daily rate at Hampstead I'm sorry I
forgot to ask that
our daily rate is uh 1506.
and this is one for
Mr White
um I heard today and yesterday you
talking about
um arpa funds that are going away and
we're bringing in general funds do you
have
um have you done sort of an analysis of
the whole
division the whole department and how
much in our fund is being replaced with
General funds
I I have not done the analysis
um when we used arpa funds
under most circumstances we always try
to operate on the principle that these
would be one-time costs we do have the
one hb2 provision for nutrition and
transportation that we talked about the
other day I think is 3.2 million if I
remember correctly
um we do have this which was a little
unprecedented I don't remember the last
time the state purchased the hospital
no others come to my mind but I can
certainly take a look at that and
identify other areas to get to your
question thank you it was just you
mentioned it
one time each day and I thought well
maybe it's maybe it's bigger than I
thought thanks
representative
isn't CFI another area or that's
happening
to the 2004 million dollars in each year
let me get back to you on that one okay
that's an as we do as well sure
all right Miss Collins
um yeah I and I forget the cfo's name
I'm so sorry that we didn't ask you more
questions
yeah
um but um so thank you do you have any
parting words of wisdom for us I I got
another question for Mr White
um but I do not thank you very much for
giving us the opportunity all right uh
and thanks for all your uh you're doing
for our kids appreciate it oh I did have
one more question to the extent that
Hampstead feels a little geographically
isolated you know the road Network there
it just doesn't seem like it can get
there from very many places to what
extent is that hindering your ability to
recruit people
really answer that
um a hundred percent but we do
um we're doing okay because we're you
know geographically located to some
larger areas that that are a big draw
for us and then those that are over the
Border just over the Border in
Massachusetts
are you following any of the proposed
licensing changes in hb2
I cannot say that I am okay all right
because a question that I would just be
curious about your opinion on what the
changes proposed in the governor's
budget around licensing for health care
providers what kind of impact that might
have on your ability to recruit there's
a tremendous number of proposed changes
but I will definitely look into that
yeah I I think it may be interesting to
you but
um all right well thank you thank you so
much uh and Mr White I had a question
for you that was a little bit bigger
than uh just the Hamstead and miss Mr
Ripple remember two years ago when Ms
rounds put together that spreadsheet
that showed the different categories of
personnel and how many there were and
what the vacancy rates were there was
there was a template that she floated on
that that was very useful
I wonder if if you have access to that
spreadsheet if you know what I'm talking
about if we could maybe pass it over to
Mr White to to give us an update yep I
remember that I have it somewhere so I
can send it over to Nathan
okay all right
um do you have any last words for us
only that I forgot to mention the hb2
provision for New Hampshire hospital for
the two hundred thousand dollars
um that was paying to replace two
vehicles
that that won't pass inspection and then
some outdated clinical equipment but
otherwise no
all right so there are a lot of people
in the crowd still is there anyone here
that wanted to speak on any of these
subjects
we're open to public comment I'm not
seeing anyone wanting to speak Mr Ripple
what did you have for us I'm just going
to comment that if you were so inclined
you could do a quick first run through
of House Bill 2 today
I didn't know if you want to do that now
or wait until Friday
I'm I'll I'll take
comments from division three how do you
how do you guys feel you got another 30
minutes in you at least to talk about
hp2
well I'm just saying at least
do you got it you got it yeah I'd like
to get started on I mean per from my I
would like to hear more about it but
yeah I don't think we can finish it
no I'm just I'm just trying to figure
out if you want to quit and go home
that's what that was my nice way of
asking that five o'clock okay okay
all right
um so that that one
uh representative money
thank you so just moments ago in our
emails we received notice from Janet
that the public hearing on house bills
one and two will be Monday March 13th at
2 p.m that just came in
reps Hall I may add
March 13th it's Monday oh no
2PM in reps Hall on the 13th
Monday the 13th standard
yes
I think we're running a little late I
tell you
just introducing the bills
yeah
okay well good
um can anybody comment on go ahead on
what that how that works what that looks
like who does the presenting what's
expected of us if anything
just listen
we're there to listen yeah it's a
public hearing on the governor's budget
so just like any other Bill the public
come and speak to that bill I mean
obviously you could ask questions but
people will come and speak and they'll
speak to certain sections of the budget
thank you
so I don't know why I'm remembering
sitting in rep Paul with with the big
book of HP two items
thinking that I had to speak to every
hb2 item in front of the division that's
the presentation that we do of our
budget when when it leaves here
the finance committee has to do a
presentation to the Full House
so then once we've got our documents all
written and together then we do a
presentation to the Full House
okay so that I remember that
Auditorium with the AstroTurf
right yeah okay yeah that's where we
were okay very good
um
do you want to S would do you have
something to hand out on hp2 or what do
you want to do how do you want to do
that well I don't so I already emailed
around although I don't have hard copies
with me uh a brief summary that I
produced of division three House Bill 2
sections and I think I've handed out
maybe not to everyone yet uh the
Department's somewhat more detailed
summary of hb2 sections so if you don't
have that I can hand it out
Mr chair
over here Mr chair
I'm supposed to be in another meeting
um I'm okay if you guys continue without
me I'm fine with that and we can catch
up later
all right
this this is not even a scheduled work
session we're about to do so we're not
going to come anywhere near any
decisions I think we're just going to
socialize these no that's fine I I don't
expect that we're exacting anything and
I'm sure all of these are going to be
rediscussed on Monday now that we're in
reps Hall okay
so if everybody has that document I
think we can get started
uh so so I can get started with this and
I think I would ask Nathan to speak to
some of the appropriation sections in
particular because
they aren't very detailed and I don't
necessarily know the rationale behind
them so I won't be able to offer much
insight into that
so the first section that pertains to
division three
is section 49 which is on page 20 of the
bill and that's a 1.5 million dollar
appropriation fiscal 23 for juvenile
peer-to-peer grief support programming
and this I believe
okay so it's not specific to the
governor's commission it's it's an
appropriation to HHS
so Nathan I don't know if you have any
comments to add on that one
um so I I've I've coordinated with Katya
Fox the director for Behavioral Health
and we will have more information on
this this was not included in our agency
budget this was added during the
governor's phase
go ahead I was going to ask a quick
question what um
division would this be under that would
or does this go to
an agency
um so I I believe the division for
Behavioral Health would most likely
manage these funds um if if an
appropriation was was made we would
likely go through either an RFP or an
RFA or an rfg process
um to distribute those funds thanks
okay and the next section that pertains
to division three is on page
31. so if we have questions we want the
department to be able to come back on to
answer should we talk about them now you
think I would yeah if you have questions
now Okay so
so this is a brand new program I believe
I've not seen adolescent peer-to-peer
grief counseling ever
so I I think we probably need a
I'll say briefing that would rationalize
or Justify this program because I've
never seen it before
in any context and I and the kinds of
things I'd be curious is uh you know how
would we identify who would be eligible
aren't there already
programs in place that are supposed to
do most of this uh what kind of
evaluation metrics would we impose so
that we would have some idea of the kind
of workload we could handle how would we
have any metrics on Effectiveness I I
just I'm just curious about this as a
pro as a program
sure and uh and and again I'll I'll have
the the team come back and um we'll also
determine whether it's an evident
evidence-based program as well
[Music]
yeah I'm gonna say it is and it probably
is and they're going to say that they
could send us the evidence and I'm never
going to read it anyways so if they
could just summarize it uh keep it tight
you know like 15 minutes I think
ought to be able to do it are there any
other questions here representative erf
do you think five minutes
okay there's a lot in hp2 if they come
back and talk about all these at 50
minutes a pop are going to be
spending the evening some evening all
right keep it tight
next okay so the next one is section 77
which is on page 31 of the build and
this is actually an appropriation of Das
for the purpose of constructing a sununu
center replacement this is 10 million
dollars in fiscal 23. on this one I
might suggest that if the committee ends
up passing a version of House Bill 49
that this could just come out
come out or be reduced I mean because
sometimes I hear people talk about belts
and suspenders you know well
possibly but it's 10 million dollars
that the finance committee will have to
account for in its budget so if you
could if you could reduce it in here it
would uh it would be a savings that
would really help you so is my math
right that I think if we've got 21.6 and
49 and we've got 15 we're hoping to get
from federal money that we're really
only talking about
6.6 million General funds
6.6 and I'm also wondering if and I know
there are two amendments out there to
house bill 49. Each of which contain
different language relative to the
appropriation I'm wondering if
there could be a third version that
potentially tweaks that language to
require uh
that the full 21.6 million come from
arpa even if that means go for
reallocating some of the existing arpa
projects
okay
next is section 89 on page 33 which is
roughly a two million dollar
appropriation in fiscal 23 for the
granite United ways administration of
the recovery friendly workplace
initiative
okay so somebody who has been around
longer on this ought to give me some
history I I understood that when we
established the governor's Commission on
Alcohol and Other Drugs that we
identified a source of funds from the
sale of alcohol and that and that they
get a big bunch of money and that
they're supposed to within that
commission allocate that money to
various things that was meant to be
outside of the general fund's budget
process but yet here we are with the
general funds request this seems to be
something new and different and a red
flag what what am I missing okay is my
assumption correct that this would be on
top of anything that the governor's
commission gets in house bill one
um yes with an Asterix but yes
then I I have nothing further to add I
think you're right it would be on top of
the five percent of liquor profits
allocated to the governor's commission
and and I I heard a rumor I think that
this is money that may have previously
come from the hospital Association and
they're withdrawing their support I
don't think this particular money is but
the funds appropriated in house bill one
uh would fall into that category yes
okay do you have something Mr White sure
yeah so um and then representative the
governor's commission as part in
agreement that predates my time
um was has been funded with with a
hospital donation so every six months uh
the association provides a five million
dollar donation the last one that we are
scheduled to receive is December of 2023
um so for the remaining six months of
State fiscal year 24 and all of c
fiscaler 25 we do not have the standard
funding that we have received right now
just kind of related question I I get
that but is this also a program that
will be the governor program that you
guys did not put into your budget or
where did this come from this was not
included in our agency submission okay
so I might suggest we do what you just
asked on the first one which is maybe we
need to hear what the why we should be
including this at all the five minute
thing at some point
who would we ask for that I I mean I I
would take an initial email explaining
why the state should pay for something
that has been done through charitable
work of our hospitals
no I don't think those are related
things are they
um not necessarily I I mean I I could
talk to the governor's office to see um
if they if they have the um you know the
ability just to give us a written
statement uh to get to get your to your
question behind this
well I think
so back to section 49 yes that was
something the governor threw in there he
wants that out he wants that whatever
that is and we don't know what it is I
was talking about 80 now no no I
understand I just want to draw a
parallel so do we know what this is or
is it a similar sort of thing we don't
know what it is only the governor knows
what it is so so I think this is another
one where I would want to bring uh the
director from division for Behavioral
Health to speak to the committee a
little bit more about this this is
outside of my my knowledge area but
isn't this something that the behavioral
health division didn't initiate this is
a governor-initiated item is it not I
thought I heard you say that yes yes
so I wouldn't ask the division to
justify something they didn't invent why
wouldn't we just ask the governor's
office on what their rationale for this
is can can we just get an email from
them since their time is busy sure we
can do that too okay all right now it's
not that I don't want to listen to our
division but I don't want to put them in
a spot where they're having to justify
something they didn't think of
do you have a question there go ahead I
think you're right I think it should be
the governor's office to tell us about
what this is because they're the one
I think for any of these that were
initiated initiated by the governor's
office rather than the department we
could include them in a list and ask the
governor's office to justify them
I I appreciate that and accept that
recommendation
so the next item is section number 99 on
page 36.
this is again an appropriation to the
governor's Commission of 1.5 million in
each year 24 and 25. for the purpose of
providing Student Assistance programming
across the state
so is this the same sort of thing as a
governor thing
so same idea this this is It's violating
to me the fundamental principle of how
we set up this commission to begin with
that it was supposed to be funded by
alcohol funds and it's not meant to be a
target for General funds so if we're
going to break that precedent I'd really
like to understand what the rationale is
okay the next section
that I had but maybe better addressed by
division two
um is on page 53 it's section 151 which
moves from HHS to the Department of
Safety the responsibility to conduct
inspections of residential care and
health facilities licensed I'm confused
I was getting ready to hear about 212
section 212.
that's next on your list so I I had
identified section 151 on page 53 as a
division three issue however I think
division two wants to address it and I
think Nathan's fine with division two
addressing it
um so if you're okay with that I'm okay
with it I'm perfectly happy letting
somebody else do the work okay
so in that case we will move on to
section 212 on page 76. which
appropriates funds for the Choose Love
program which I believe is something
that was
first approved by the fiscal committee
as well as two related classified
positions
can I ask a question
please thanks I remember this being
um the legislature passed it last year I
remember there was a little bit of
pageantry around it or some women in the
gallery
would it is this shouldn't this have
gone into hb1
if it was something that was
legislatively passed and
um I I
my understanding is this currently
resides within the governor's office was
in the within the executive branch and
there's a couple of different ways that
you could transfer a program and
sometimes you have to do it statutorily
um and you know you you could move the
class lines which would what you would
see you know coming out of hb1 so if we
can't you know cut out the class line
within the executive branch and move
that over that would be one component of
it
um I don't know the surrounding RSA
behind this
um or or whether that would be required
if it came through fiscal then there
likely isn't any so I mean I think hb2
is a vehicle that could be used for this
purpose
so this is School curriculum and it's
being administered through the
Department of Health and Human Services
how how does it reach students I
wouldn't have to go through the
Department of Education so just to be
clear this is transferring the program
to HHS to Public Health Services where
it doesn't currently reside
um and and and this is this is the
movement that's what this action is
doing it's moving it to the department
so I I can't speak to the specific
programmatic nature but I can get Trisha
Tilley or some others here to to talk to
that or I can get it to you in writing
so it's already like in the Department
of Education and it's being moved to
Public Health or is it in it's somewhere
in the department and it's just being a
divisional move or something so there's
two positions I believe they're both
filled I believe the funding and the
positions are coming from the governor's
office
to HHS
all right thank you yep
I I I think I'd be open to reading an
email
explanation sure
anyone disagree with that Representative
no I'm just I just Googled very quickly
New Hampshire Choose Love program and
their page is under the Department of
Education
so I'm just curious how it ended up in
DHHS but
if it's curriculum I don't know that the
department should touch it
it's not like the department is an
expert on love
I like the description where it says no
cost and they want 250 000 for it for no
cost
okay
all right
so the next section is section 213
which allows HHS to fill unfunded
positions during the biennium provided
that expenditures do not exceed the
amount appropriated for personnel costs
at this point I think this is
boilerplate the department has had it
for the last several budget sessions
there may have been one or two in there
where it was removed but in general
they've had it for the better part of
the last 10 years and there are a couple
of other agencies that have had this as
well periodically I think safety and
transportation have had versions of it
at some point
I would be curious to see
the last 10 years or at least the last
say six years
okay I can find the history of that
so so can I just ask you about your
workload right now Mr Ripple because
you're also supporting the Senate you're
supporting us you're supporting all uh
how are you doing are you are you full
are you at 50 hours and more a week or
where where are you
probably but that's
but that's no problem
okay so are we getting close to Breaking
you no no not just yet not yet okay keep
asking
uh the next section is section 214 which
suspends the Foster grandparent program
for the biennium
um again at this point this is sort of
boilerplate I believe it was suspended
beginning in the 1213 biennium
and has not been funded since with one
exception I think it was funded in the
2021 budget however I think the
department did not actually expend that
appropriation
upon I saw this was um
was still suspended this is this is this
is different than what I was expecting
is there another place somewhere where
we killed the or suspended the the uh
the Foster grandparent program or is
that a different program
the grand Foster program or something
I'm not sure
say again
there are some other suspensions if
that's what you're asking
okay I thought this was
the way I'm reading this is this is an
unsuspension and they're going to want
right so usually what they we do is we
suspend it for the biennium so they said
we suspended for the last for the
current biennium and this is saying
suspended for the next biennium okay
I guess I'm just not reading it right
then as a newbie can I just ask a
question why would you do that
why are we not do we not have a foster
grandparent program anymore pretty much
there isn't one currently as it hasn't
been operational for the last 10 years
but I think as with a couple of other
areas here the appetite hasn't
necessarily been there to suspend it
outright to repeal it outright okay so
the legislature has just ended up
suspending it for the biennium instead
so pending legislation to repeal the
program this is just what you do yeah
yeah okay thanks that's what gets done I
don't like doing that if it's a program
that we don't think we're ever going to
turn back on I just as soon turn this
hb2 item into an outright repeal and be
done with it we can do that
go ahead the program exists we just
aren't giving it any
funding
we weren't funding the whole thing it's
it's a program that exists in New
Hampshire and the um
the state was making a small
contribution to it it's got a federal
funds United Way funds but it still
exists there are still Foster
grandparent programs and there are
people who would like to see the state
once again engaging in funding part of
it
all right thank you
next the next section is essentially the
same thing but for the congregate
housing and Services Program it's also
suspended for the biennium and has been
for approximately the last 10 years
again the one exception being it was
funded in the 2021 budget but the
department did not expend those funds
um
so the next section is section 216 which
increases the income eligibility for
elderly and adult clients clients under
the social services block grant each
January by the percentage amount of any
cost of living increase in Social
Security benefits again I would say by
this point this is boilerplate It's
appeared in the last several trailer
bills
celebrating more than two
yes
again I could I could take a look at the
history but it's been at least two okay
well but more than two more than two I
it's it has to be okay I'll check though
but it has to be
so as you're looking at it and thinking
about it if there's an if there's
another long-term solution to this like
legislation introduced next January or
something which you would you please cue
me in on that because I I would like us
to be working towards cleaning up hb2
and reducing the amount of burden on it
okay
in fact this is the kind of thing that
if you wanted to offer an amendment to
remove the stipulation that it's for the
biennium only it could be made permanent
I'm not sure what the consequences if
any of that would be but it would be a
pretty simple fix
representative norgren would would you
all maybe caucus at some point and talk
about whether or not you'd be open to
I I'd rather fix things longer than
shorter
the next section is always confusing
it's section 217 which delays until July
1st of 25 the prospective repeal and
reenactment of RSA 135 C13 which is
relative to access to the state's Mental
Health Services System and this is
essentially a cost savings measure it
allows Community Mental Health Centers
to to assess the need of prospective
clients and it requires them to work
within the confines of the available
Appropriations for these services
have copies of the uh
relevant statute if anybody wants to see
those
I I saw a representative nodding so I
think we're I'm okay with this
anyone have an issue
did I misinterpret your nod
can we hold on this
can can we hold on this
yeah yeah
why don't we try to set a time we will
go until
what would you suggest like quarter to
five four Thirty sold quarter to five it
is
4 30. I hear 4 30. do I hear a 428
it sold at 4 30.
the next section is another suspension
this is section 218 which suspends
direct and indirect graduate medical
education payments for the biennium
so this is another one this is the
candidate for us to just change it from
a biennium to a permanent suspension
it could potentially if there if the
appetite exists for that what do you
what do you think representative norgren
to you do do you want to think about it
do you want to caucus on that and come
back later
okay
all right I I just would like like I
said I just would like to make as many
of these cleanups as possible yeah thank
you
same thing with Section 219 which
suspends catastrophic Aid payments to
hospitals for the biennium
okay moving on to section 220 this do
you know how many um
bienniums that's been in there
I can take a look I think the vast
majority of these have been in here
since the 1213 budget
does Nathan have something
yes so um I I'd ask the the team just to
take a look at these past two section
218 graduate medical education payments
the best that we could identify that
they were last paid in 2006
um we believe it was roughly 1.58
million dollars and then for the
suspension of catastrophic Aid to
hospitals
um we we found this back in 2011
um it was about three million dollars
back at that point
section 220 relates to the Medicaid to
schools program that says that in the
event Appropriations are insufficient
HHS May accept and expend funds uh
additional federal funds through fiscal
and report to fiscal and the types of
assistance the department is providing
to school districts to ensure
eligibility for reimbursement this first
appeared in the trailer Bill two years
ago and I think it was in response to uh
a pressing issue at the time of school
districts not receiving reimbursement
for certain services so this section was
added so two questions do we think it's
really still needed or is it just a
Vestige uh
tool now
I'm not sure I would ask Nathan to weigh
in
can you verify if this is still a
current need or might we have just
inherited this out of habit sure we we
had requested it um just because a lot
of work has been done on the Medicaid
the schools program to get guidance out
there to the schools to try to bring
more on
um and and we had requested this just
due to the unknown surrounding that I
think the important thing to remember
about this is the the match the
non-federal match portion is coming from
the local school district so that so the
the there's no general fund costs
associated with this it would simply
allow us to get the matching federal
dollars for the Medicaid costs would we
be putting the local school districts on
the hook for mandatorily accepting
a match obligation or would they still
have the discretion locally to
participate or not this this really
doesn't address that question I I don't
see any mandate here this is more so
just the the financial mechanism that we
would use to draw down those federal
funds in the event that what we have
budgeted exceeds the amount so
okay
next is section 221 which makes funds
appropriated to the division of Medicaid
services non-lapsing until June 30th
2025 and treats them as restricted
revenue for the purpose of funding
Medicaid Managed Care throughout the
biennium this was done in the 2021
trailer bill but I wouldn't describe it
as boilerplate at all and it does have a
general fund lapse impact and I think
Nathan I think you said in your
summary that it would be about 5 million
that absent this section would otherwise
last to the general fund yes that that
is correct um we we don't see this as a
long-term hb2 provision by any means um
this is this is to address the uh record
number of individuals that we do have
enrolled in Medicaid today within the
state where a little over 250 000
um which is significantly higher than
our historical figures we we do you know
we continue to have a number of unknowns
and we've talked to and Henry lippman
talked about this when he came before
you
um and and we will be having the 6.2
phase out here to five percent then two
and a half and then one and a half
percent of the additional fmap and we we
had requested this just to attempt to
address any of those potential
fluctuations
um that we may see resulting from the
appeal process as we disenroll
individuals because if they appeal they
have the ability to continue to main on
remain on uh the Medicaid roll until we
can uh formally final is that appeal
to just put it out there I I think I'm
okay with this unless somebody has a
reason to tell me why we shouldn't be
but carrying the 5 million over
makes sense it's another shock absorber
okay and next is section 222 which
requires hhs2 if necessary submit a
Medicaid State Plan amendment to
establish and provide preventative
health care benefits under the Medicaid
Program and this section is new and has
not appeared in previous trailer bills
go ahead I was just going to ask if
Nathan went to tell us what exactly it's
doing sure I I will do my best and while
you're doing it I'm wondering how much
redundancy there is because we have
other smoking secession programs
the
so I I can't answer that question what I
can do and the information here
coordinated with Henry and Dr Ballard on
essentially
um we we likely have funds within the
Medicaid budget
um to to pay for these types of
evidence-based programs that have based
on the studies that you that you see
there that have reduced long-term and
short-term costs in other states and so
this provision would allow us to engage
in those
so I may have some comments when we talk
about it it's a national preventative
task force something that has influenced
a lot of health insurance that I'm
there's something called the national
preventative task force that
um
provides uh recommendations on items and
services that are other themselves cost
effective requires certain insurance
companies to pay for them without copay
for example
or outside the deductible boat
we can talk about it when it comes up
just because there's no budgetary impact
correct that is correct
there's no budgetary no dollar impact
Our Hope though is that the long-term
budget impact will be a net reduction in
costs due to
by having this
available as opposed to by it costing
money to do this yes
okay next is section 223 which
appropriates funds for the purpose of
operating the sununu center throughout
the biennium and this is slightly over
11 million in general funds per year
so so my general thought on this is that
it would be great to get Mr ribson to
explain what this how he got to this or
how you and he got to this number you
know how what what kind of personnel are
we looking at what kind of other
operating expenses are we looking at so
so normally we would have that when this
is an HP one but we don't have it here
in hp2 so it's that level of detail I
think we could we still need to get to
sure
oh go ahead my question would be would
we wouldn't we move this once we get
that level of detail wouldn't we move
this into hb1
I I I mean my my hope would be that we
can get this into the operating budget
it was in hp2 because of the because of
the the pending closure date
um I can submit a change request that
gives you that class line level detail
of of what's behind these numbers here
well that would do it for me I I just
would add that we need we would still
need to have somebody come back and talk
to us specifically about what's in there
I I I if we're going to start moving
towards this therapeutic model I I want
to understand how we would be doing this
and that and this biennium and what it's
doing just change the positions that are
being requested
okay next is section 224 which allows
the department to transfer between and
create certain class lines in order to
comply with Federal standards and this
one again I believe is new
all right so
um you heard me previously talk about
sub-recipients and contractors and
you've seen a number of movements within
within our class lines where they go
from 74 to 102. um when we when we
budget uh before we get a grant we may
not necessarily know
how are we going to use all of those
dollars and sometimes plans change out
of the federal funds sometimes we have
to have any of our any of our budgets
approved by the feds sometimes through
those conversations plans can change
based on their directives and so we have
to account for whether whether something
should be accounted for in a class 74 if
it's a sub-recipient and and that can
still be a contract it could be a grant
it could be an mou or some other type of
agreement or whether it's a contractor
under the federal definition into CFR
200 through 331 so we were we were
asking uh the the for consideration as
to whether we would have the ability to
move the funds within those class lines
and not come back through fiscal and I
will defer to you on on the Judgment
there
okay next is section 225 which moves
from HHS to safety the responsibility to
conduct preliminary inspection and
approval for new facilities or
alterations to existing facilities
licensed under RSA 151 and Nathan is
this similar to the one that we've
gifted to division two
um that's not okay
let's move it so we don't deal with it
in this budget
well well so so it's it's pretty I'd
like to think it's pretty simple anyway
um so during during the uh Governor's
phase Melissa saying sir when she was
here she's our chief legal officer we
abolished two positions within the
department and the department of safety
created two positions in their
Department we reduced our general funds
I don't remember off the top of my head
I think it was close to
237 thousand dollars and they don't
quote me on it but I can come back with
it and they increase their General funds
to cover those positions and the reason
that we were doing that is because these
functions uh that that are being
transferred here from the Department of
Health and Human Services to the
Department of Safety make a lot more
sense to be within the functions of the
Department of Safety and less less So
within the Department of Health and
Human Services
the section 155 that division two is
taking up um I don't quite know the
origin of that but I've spoken with the
governor's office I've spoken with Steve
Lavoy at the department of safety and
we're all in agreement that that should
go
so we now have less than five minutes
and we're not going to finish this so is
there any one specific or too specific
items that are so critical that we
should jump ahead and and talk about
them or
stay in the order okay
next
okay section 226 delays until July 1st
of 2025 implementation of the health
care facility work workplace violence
prevention program
so I've had Outreach from from from uh
the constituents not understanding why
this is being delayed so so we'll have
to talk about and uh Mr chairman you
might recall this it's you know what
this program is it's the one okay all
right I think it should not be delayed
personally
if
I want to under I want to understand
what why we're doing the delay what the
what was described to me by a lobbyist
is that the DHHS did not believe that
they had the manpower to implement this
program in this biennium
and it was my understanding when we set
this program up that it it wasn't it was
a basically a
Hospital Association LED and coordinated
effort I don't know why we're doing we
have to worry much about Manpower so if
they could come back and explain that to
us I I never thought this was a program
that the state needed to mandate I I
compromised with them I think
um and and if the department can't
support it I wouldn't mind delaying it
another two years let the hospital
Association figure out how to run the
program that they wanted
I I the the challenge that we've had is
is um when the legislation passed is
there was no appropriation or or
positions tied to that
um if if the committee wishes I can
certainly put forward a request for
Staffing for that purpose that was done
intentionally
that wasn't an accident that was you
know the the hospital Association thinks
this is important it's a Manpower issue
that they're having a problem with this
is their solution you know and so we the
the fact that we didn't appropriate or
put positions on it was an intentional
thing at the time go ahead I'm just
curious so your recollection is it
actually does require I thought it was
like a monthly meetings or something
that they were holding is actually
requires the department to do something
I do not remember the exact final
legislation I I remember the general
brush on this was
if deer Hospital Association if you want
this don't ask the state to make it
mandatory don't ask us to be spending
money on it you do it as essentially a
volunteer program and we will give you
the sort of the official recognition
that you're doing something but we're
not going to be accountable for it
can I ask Mr replica go ahead Mr but
could you just look up the law not right
now but let us know what the RSA is or
the chapter Law whatever so we just we
could read and understand what in fact
it was supposed to do or not do yep I'll
find it
wrong
we can take our house bill too and when
we're bored in the house floor tomorrow
we can
again